bien monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
mes chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir pour une audition
conjointe entre la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire du
développement durable et la commission
des finances messieurs David Valence
Bruno cavanier et Pierre-Alain roche
respectivement président vice-président
et rapporteur général du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures
comme vous le savez le COI a été
institué de manière pérenne par
l'article 3 de la Lomme avec pour
mission de conseiller le gouvernement
sur la programmation des investissements
en matière de mobilité il a succédé à la
commission mobilité 21 institué dès 2013
et fait suite au coi de première
génération de 2018 dont le rapport avait
inspiré les travaux de la Lom depuis
2019 le COI a remis trois rapports un
premier rapport sur la stratégie
nationale de développement du frais de
ferroviaire en 2021 le rapport bilan et
perspective des investissements pour les
transports et les mobilités en mars 2022
dressant le bilan du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron en matière de
politique de transport enfin le rapport
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui et qui
s'institule investir plus et mieux dans
les mobilités pour réussir leur
transition
ce rapport examine trois stratégies
d'investissement possible à horizon 2042
en matière de transport et ce dans une
optique de transition écologique du
secteur avant toute chose pourriez-vous
nous présenter les grandes lignes de
votre rapport et la méthodologie qui a
été la vôtre vous avez élaboré trois
scénarios de programmation différent du
moins ambitieux au plus ambitieux un
premier scénario dit de cadrage
budgétaire se place dans la continuité
de la trajectoire
financière de la l'homme vous indiquez
d'emblée que celui-ci ne permettra pas
de répondre aux objectifs aux objectifs
affichés par le gouvernement constat que
nous partageons dès lors vous avez
construit deux autres scénarios
scénarios plus ambitieux que la l'homme
un scénario de planification écologique
et un scénario de priorité aux
infrastructures donnant des marges de
manœuvre supplémentaires pour de
nouveaux projets
nous souhaiterions donc particulièrement
vous entendre sur ces deux derniers
scénarios afin d'enseigne dans tenir et
dans saisir les tenants et les
aboutissants à la lumière de vos
conclusions le gouvernement devra
bientôt rendre ses arbitrages et les
traduire au niveau législatif avez-vous
des informations concernant le véhicule
législatifs qui sera privilégié et le
calendrier prévu pour son examen il
semble que le gouvernement hésite entre
une nouvelle loi d'orientation des
mobilités et le simple ajout d'un volet
transport dans la future loi de
programmation sur l'énergie et le climat
la première option nous semblerait la
plus efficace pour porter une politique
une politique de transport claire une
politique de transport ambitieuse
permettez-moi également de vous
interroger sur les annonces faites par
la première ministre en mars de la
remise de ce rapport
s'agissant du plan d'investissement dans
les infrastructures ferroviaires qui
devraient être dotés de 100 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2040 le gouvernement a
laissé planer un certain flou quant aux
modalités de financement de ce plan il a
simplement été indiqué que la route est
le secteur aérien seraient mis à
contribution
avez-vous des précisions à nous apporter
sur ce point quel levier de financement
vous semblerait pertinent
enfin je souhaite évoquer le chantier de
la liaison ferroviaire Lyon Turin un
méga projet d'infrastructure qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du réseau
trans-européen de transport et que notre
commission suit a été attention alors
que le calendrier actuel prévoit un
achèvement des travaux d'ici 2030 en vue
d'une mise en service pour 2032 le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas rendu sa
décision sur les voies d'accès au tunnel
à cet égard votre rapport peut
surprendre le scénario planification
écologique que vous proposez prévoit que
les études nouvelles des nouvelles
lignes de tunnels et d'accès seraient
reportés au quinquennat 2028 2039 pour
un engagement des travaux nécessaires
pour la période 2038 2042 il préconise
en août d'accélérer la modernisation de
la ligne ferroviaire reliant et
existante Dijon à Modane s à comprendre
que vous préconisez d'ici à 2045
d'utiliser cette ligne comme seule voie
d'accès au tunnel cela peut s'apparenter
à une douche froide pour de nombreux
acteurs qui plaident en faveur d'un
scénario à grand gabarit
grand gabarit plus favorable au fret et
plus cohérent avec les choix actés par
nos voisins italiens en août un tel
scénario
et le problème est important conduirait
à dépasser largement l'échéance de 2028
marquant l'expiration de la déclaration
d'utilité publique de la partie
française pouvez-vous nous faire part de
vos réflexions sur ce sujet ce
glissement de calendrier ne risque-t-il
pas de remettre à mal ce projet déjà
bien engagé je vous remercie
quelques mots complémentaire mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le Président du
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures je le vice-président à
Bruno c'est un local voilà monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances mes chers collègues à la suite
du président Jean-François Longeot je me
réjouis que nos deux commissions réunies
puissent entendre ce matin Monsieur
David Valence président de conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures
Monsieur Bruno cavanier vice-président
et Monsieur Pierre Alain Roche
rapporteur général le 24 février dernier
le COI a présenté son rapport tant
attendu je dis tant attendu car il a été
maintes fois annoncé depuis la fin de
l'année dernière avant d'être remis il y
a de cela trois semaines à madame la
Première ministre il a été annoncé et il
était très attendu effectivement par
nous
les enjeux notamment financiers et la
sensibilité considérable de ce rapport
plus particulièrement dans le contexte
actuel de transition écologique des
transports ne sont sans doute pas pour
rien dans ce délai qui n'a fait qu'à
croître notre impatience je le disais en
tant que président de la commission des
finances je note qu'un effet marquant de
votre rapport et que vous vous êtes
affranchi du cadre budgétaire qui avait
été défini à l'origine par le
gouvernement dans votre scénario central
vous le dépassez quand même de comment
dire plus de 50%
ce qui n'est pas tout à fait rien votre
rapport décrit d'ailleurs très bien le
calibrage manifestement suffisant de ce
temps enveloppe initial et son
incohérence par rapport aux objectifs
qui vous étaient par ailleurs fixés par
le gouvernement dans sa lettre de
mission
ce travail d'expertise de transparence
budgétaire pour mettre en cohérence des
objectifs ambitieux et les moyens qu'il
suppose me semble particulièrement
précieux j'aimerais savoir cependant
qu'elle a été la réaction du ministre
des Finances lorsque vous lui avez
annoncé votre intention
votre scénario central dit de
planification écologique prévoit des
investissements tout financeur confondus
de plus de 84 milliards d'euros entre
2023 et 2027 puis de plus de 90
milliards d'euros entre 2028 et 2032
toujours selon ce scénario la vie de
France et à travers elle l'État devrait
contribuer à hauteur d'un tiers la
question des modalités de financement de
ces investissements et de la répartition
de la charge entre les différents
financeurs et devant nous et elle
s'annonce complexe
j'aimerais recueillir votre sentiment
sur les annonces de la première ministre
suite à la remise de votre rapport si de
nombreux paramètres restent à éclaircir
elle a déclaré vouloir prendre comme
travail votre scénario central je vous
fais de la parole monsieur le Président
pour que vous puissiez présenter votre
rapport avant d'engager le débat avec
nos rapporteurs pour ce qui concerne la
commission des finances Hervé Moret et
Stéphane sotarel et l'ensemble de nos
collègues je vous rappelle que votre
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat et j'ose dire qu'elle sera
regardée monsieur le président
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Longeot monsieur le Président
rénal monsieur le rapporteur général du
budget cher Jean-François chers
collègues parlementaire merci de votre
invitation d'abord je suis très avec
Bruno cavanier mon vice-président et le
rapporteur général Pierre à Laroche très
heureux de d'être aujourd'hui devant la
Chambre haute qui compte de nombreux
spécialistes des transports et je ne le
dis pas pour attendrir les échanges qui
viendront après mais je le dis très
sincèrement je sais que beaucoup de
sénateurs qui sont ici présents ont
travaillé sur ces questions
d'infrastructure ou d'usage des
transports et que la chambre haute a
toujours montré à ses sujets une
attention très signalée alors quelques
mots d'abord à l'invitation du président
Longeot sur la méthode et la manière
dont nous avons travaillé ensuite je
vous parlerai un peu des résultats en
effet et puis quelques points de
vigilance aussi par rapport à la manière
dont notre rapport a pu être lu
interprété décortiqué avant même sa
remise du reste puisque certaines de ces
versions provisoires avaient fuité dans
les médias
la méthode d'abord président lonjo l'a
dit le Conseil tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui elle successeur d'un certain
nombre de structures cette structure qui
avait élaboré le schéma national des
infrastructures de transport il y a déjà
plus de 10 ans maintenant il y a eu
mobilité 21 qui était des structures
Haddock c'est-à-dire composées
spécifiquement pour élaborer un rapport
et qui aussitôt ce rapport élaboré se
dissolvait et puis le Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures
première version
présidée par mon prédécesseur Philippe
Durand spécialiste reconnu des
transports et qui avait remis en 2018 à
l'automne un rapport qui a largement
nourri les travaux de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités en tant
qu'elles retenait un certain nombre
d'opérations de financement
d'infrastructures sans être pour autant
une loi de programmation ce que pour le
moment nous n'avons pas eu en France
depuis très très longtemps sur nos
sujets d'infrastructures de transport et
donc le législateur a fait le choix de
pérenniser le gouvernement en
particulier pérenniser cette structure
je le dis d'autant plus volontiers que
c'est on le sait les membres du conseil
qui sont ici présent il y a trois
sénateurs Christine herzogh Philippe
Tabarro et Michel Dagbert qui ont été
très investis dans nos travaux le savent
c'était une volonté personnelle de la
première ministre que de pérenniser le
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures à l'époque où elle était
ministre des transports notamment parce
que cet outil
il faut à la fois pas surestimer la
portée de ses travaux au sens où ça
n'est pas le COI qui décide je crois que
c'est important de le dire et en même
temps c'est un outil d'objectivation des
choix publics et le choix de la
pérennisation allait bien dans ce
sens-là c'est à dire que on a on peut le
dire ici parfois sur ces sujets
d'infrastructure de transport empilés
les décisions sur le plan chronologique
sur le plan des modes de transport et il
y avait une nécessité ressentie en 2018
et du coup avec la pérennisation du coi
par la suite de redonner de la
crédibilité aux engagements publics sur
les sujets d'infrastructures de
transport et c'était l'objet principal
du conseil que d'essayer de mettre en
face les engagements et les capacités à
faire sur le plan financier mais pas
seulement sur le plan financier du reste
et donc cette pérennisation elle est
intervenue aujourd'hui on a un conseil
qui est placé auprès du ministre des
transport qui ne peut pas s'auto saisir
l'important de le dire un certain nombre
de sujets sur lesquels on aimerait les
uns les autres travailler que ce soit
sur précisément ces sujets de
financement des infrastructures dans les
années qui viennent sur lesquels on n'a
pas eu le temps de se pencher en
quelques mois après après la saisine du
ministre des Transports le 7 octobre
dernier ou sur le sujet de la transition
de la route par exemple il y aurait de
quoi travailler donc pas d'auto saisine
un conseil qui est composé pour une
large part d'élus que c'est important de
le dire des représentants des
associations d'élus l'Assemblée des
départements de France avec François
Durovray de région de France avec Michel
leugnot pour Bourgogne Franche-Comté de
de France
urbaine avec Louis bien sûr trois
sénateurs que j'ai cités 3 députés deux
députés européennes qui sont invités
permanentes Fabienne Keller et Karima
Delhi et puis des
spécialiste des sujets de transport dans
leur diversité et au premier rang
desquels notre apporteur général pire à
la roche qui préside la section
transport de l'inspection générale de
l'environnement et du développement
durable et donc la valeur des
appréciations et des analyses qui sont
fournis par le COI est à la mesure de sa
capacité à dégager du consensus sur les
sujets qu'il aborde et je tiens à dire
que dans les trois scénariques que nous
avons examiné celui qui correspondait à
la lettre mission du gouvernement d'une
part celui qui est le scénario central
de planification écologique d'autre part
et le scénario de priorité aux
infrastructures enfin celui qui
recueille le plus large un sentiment
c'est le scénario central qui
véritablement est composé de composantes
qui font tout largement consensus au
sein de la commission même si
certains de nos membres et c'est
notamment vrai pour le scénario 3 je
vous rassure tout de suite personne n'a
plaidait vraiment pour le scénario 1 au
sein du Conseil peut-être au déplaisir
des membres de la commission des
finances du Sénat mais et donc néanmoins
certains d'entre nous auraient pu
souhaiter quelque chose d'encore plus
ambitieux pour pouvoir tenir les
calendriers en accéléré certains de
certains projets et donc le scénario 3 a
un certain nombre avait un certain
nombre d'adeptes au sein du conseil et
certains sont présents dans cette salle
donc
par conséquent je dirais que nos travaux
qui ont commencé le donc je le disais le
7 octobre qui se sont poursuivis lors de
plus d'une dizaine de réunions parfois
de journées entières
consacrées à des auditions mais aussi à
des débats entre nous qui ont pu être
vifs peut-être plus que par le passé et
bien on a pu élaborer ce document qui
était globalement prêt à la fin de
l'année dernière et qui a fait l'objet
ensuite d'échanges réguliers vous le
savez avec avec le gouvernement avant sa
remise ça c'est pour la méthode et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président Longeot
ça n'est pas le premier rapport du coi
c'est le troisième sous cette
composition et depuis que j'ai été nommé
président avant d'être député
en février 2021
avec pour ce dernier rapport une assez
grande filiation avec le précédent
puisque dans le précédent on faisait le
bilan de la remontée des attentes des
territoires en matière d'infrastructure
de transport avec d'ailleurs on peut se
le dire ici on est devant aussi la
chambre des collectivités territoriales
dans la manière dont ces attentes
avaient été filtrées des grandes
différences avec des régions qui avaient
fait et des métropoles l'effort de
prioriser leur projet et d'autres qui
étaient arrivés avec je dirais
un sac d'attente assez assez complet et
assez fournie sans vouloir les
hiérarchiser pour des raisons qu'on peut
imaginer ça c'est pour la méthode
sur les résultats on a en effet choisi
de s'affranchir très vite du scénario de
référence qui correspondait à la
trajectoire de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités qui représentaient déjà un
effort sur les infrastructures de
transport supérieur à ce qui avait été
fait au cours des années précédentes je
crois qu'il faut le souligner et y
insister
mais et donc abonder de
3,3 milliards d'euros possiblement en
arriver à 17,5 pour l'espace du
quinquennat mais on a aussi choisi de
s'en affranchir pas seulement sur le
montant de cette lettre de mission mais
aussi sur ça durée l'année de mission du
ministre transport prévoyait que le
rapport porterait sur l'espace de deux
quinquennats et nous avons fait le choix
donc jusque possiblement 2032 nous avons
fait le choix de travailler sur l'espace
de quatre quinquennat
au moins et même au-delà pour certains
des projets parce que le temps des
infrastructures c'est un temps long on
le sait au moment où nous parlons nous
voyons aboutir certains des
investissements du Grand Paris qui est
initiative qui a été prise on le sait
lors du quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy
et c'est maintenant que les projets
sortent de terre et aboutissent ça n'est
qu'un exemple parmi d'autres donc on
s'en est affranchi et ce scénario de de
planification écologique qui est
vraiment le scénario central celui qui a
rassemblé le plus grand nombre des
membres et je dirais tous les membres
certains voulant plus mais personne ne
voulant vraiment moins il a quelques
caractéristiques le message central
qu'il passe c'est d'abord le message de
la priorité à l'utilisation à la
modernisation et au développement des
infrastructures existantes et ceci est
vrai du reste quel que soit les types
d'infrastructures je crois que c'est
évidemment sur le ferroviaire que
beaucoup des attentions ont porté parce
que c'est c'est là probablement que
l'effort de rattrapage était le plus
immédiatement sensible
dans ce qu'on formulait comme attente
mais ce message là il est valable aussi
pour la route sur lequel le message du
Conseil reprenant celui de qui a été
formulé en 2018 c'est
réussir la transition de la route
c'est-à-dire faire de ce patrimoine
exceptionnel qui nous a été légué par
des des
siècles d'aménagement routiers et qui
est je crois l'un des tous premiers
peut-être même le premier réseau routier
d'Europe de faire de ce patrimoine
exceptionnel quelque chose d'adapté au
monde dans lequel nous vivons avec bien
sûr la nécessité de bornes de recharge
électrique d'un usage partagé de la
route etc etc et nous n'en sommes qu'au
début donc ce message central de la
priorisation à l'utilisation des
infrastructures existantes à leur
modernisation et ou à leur développement
c'est l'une des clés de ce qui est
recommandé dans ce scénario central et
je le dis souvent
ne nous disons pas quand on parle de
priorité à l'aménagement de ce qui
existe à sa transition à sa
modernisation ne nous disons pas ça ne
se voit pas parce que là aussi je
m'adresse à des élus qui savent comment
parfois le message de création d'une
infrastructure nouvelle peut être plus
entraînant et donner une impression de
volontarisme plus plus fort que celui de
la modernisation de ce qui existe ou de
sa régénération dans l'étape précédente
donc ça c'est le message central pour
autant
pour autant ce scénario central n'exclut
pas des projets d'infrastructures
nouvelles
tout au plus pas plus qu'il ne repousse
au calendes ou remet en cause par
exemple le grand projet
sud-ouest à grande vitesse dans lequel
notamment sur la section Bordeaux -
Toulouse le potentiel de report modal de
l'avion vers le train est avéré et
renseigné aujourd'hui mais c'est vrai
que le message central c'est celui-là la
priorité de cette utilisation des
infrastructures
avec singulièrement NFC une poursuite de
l'effort et de la montée en puissance
des investissements sur le fluvial je
rappelle que au cours du quinquennat
précédent il a été investi deux fois
plus que lors du quinquennat qu'il a
précédé sur le réseau fluvial donc on a
besoin d'un maintien de ces efforts et
ceci dans un contexte où voie navigable
de France a montré à l'occasion du plan
de relance qu'elle savait utiliser les
crédits qu'on lui accordait et
effectivement sur le ferroviaire d'un
effort
c'est quand que nous souhaitons à une
hauteur de d'au moins un milliard
d'euros dès la fin de ce quinquennat
pour la modernisation
là pardon la régénération et 500
millions pour la modernisation et ce
site façon récurrente parce que vous
m'entendrez le dire à la fois dans cette
interventionaire et dans les réponses
que nous pouvons formuler
autant que le combien le comment est
important en matière d'infrastructure de
transport je crois que tout le monde en
est convaincu ici mais il faut le dire
et le comment c'est aussi la récurrence
de cet effort
consacré comme il a été proposé dans un
amendement à l'Assemblée Nationale 3
milliards sur une seule année en effort
et du jour au lendemain à
l'investissement dans notre réseau
ferroviaire dans l'état actuel de la
capacité à faire de la SNCF ça n'a pas
de sens ce qui compte beaucoup plus
c'est d'avoir cet effort constant
continue et prévisible
également pour les entreprises
d'ailleurs qui sont les sous-traitants
de la SNCF je rappelle toujours que
c'est un secteur économique et on le dit
qui représente des plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'emplois et il faut le dire y
compris quand on discute avec le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
donc c'est ce scénario central il
représente par rapport à ce qui était
prévu une demande d'investissement un
besoin d'investissement qui est non
seulement augmenté au cours de ce
quinquennat on est à plus de 25
milliards d'euros contre une je le
disais une commande à 17 à peu près mais
avec une montée en puissance dans le
quinquennat suivant où on dépassera les
29,4 milliards d'euros souhaité par le
scénario donc c'est pas ça n'est pas un
effort en cliquet et qui redescend
immédiatement que nous recommandons
c'est bien un effort constant continue
et prévisible j'y insiste qui privilégie
c'est peut-être aussi l'une des
singularités par rapport aux rapports
précédents de façon très claire dans la
priorisation des projets les projets qui
ont un potentiel de décarbonation avérée
des déplacements qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs les déplacements de
marchandises ou les déplacements de de
voyageurs
je serai pas plus long sur le détail de
ce scénario central parce que je pense
que les questions évidemment sont
nombreuses et sur les points de
vigilance je le disais par rapport à ce
qui a été retenu du rapport dans sa
présentation et je donnerai sans doute
la parole dans l'accepte dans quelques
instants à mon camarade Bruno cavanier
sur les sujets de financement
d'abord encore une fois le l'un des
sujets centraux c'est la capacité à
faire
la capacité à faire sur les métiers la
capacité à faire sur la maîtrise
d'ouvrage les maîtrises d'oeuvres
dans nos investissements de dans les
infrastructures de transport et on peut
d'ailleurs lire ce qui a été évoqué par
la première ministre lors d'un remise du
rapport sur le fait d'identifier la
Société du Grand Paris comme étant le
véhicule qui pourrait réaliser les
réseaux Express métropolitain
en France on peut le voir aussi comme
une réponse à cette capacité à faire
puisqu'on sait que si on est dans
l'effort que nous identifions SNCF
réseau va avoir un plan d'investissement
important une montée en charge très
importante et continue à conduire et
peut-être plus de difficultés à
travailler en plateau projet sur des
créations d'infrastructures nouvelles ou
d'infrastructures complexes
mais la capacité à faire est un sujet
central et et à cet égard si je
concentre
l'oeil sur le sujet du ferroviaire
il y a une vraie nécessité d'un
changement de culture à SNCF réseau dans
la capacité à expliquer ce qui est fait
aux différents financeurs à respecter
des délais et à évaluer l'état réels de
son patrimoine au préalable autrement
qu'à dire d'experts parce que là aussi
j'imagine que dans la salle certains
l'ont vécu le les retours réguliers
auprès des élus pour appeler que ce soit
auprès d’ailleurs des élus nationaux des
élus régionaux des besoins
d'investissement sans une vue globale de
ce que ce que pourrait être l'évolution
de l'état de l'infrastructure dans le
temps et sous forme d'engagement c'est
quelque chose qui est difficile à
comprendre et à supporter
une deuxième chose qui est qui me paraît
être un des angles morts parfois de la
manière dont notre rapport a été reçu
c'est la capacité à évaluer au sens
large
capacité à évaluer le potentiel de
décarbonation réelle des projets
d'infrastructures je le dis très
volontiers je crois que ce constat est
partagé par tout le monde au sein du
conseil
nous avons été assez surpris de voir que
sur beaucoup de projets
d'infrastructures quels qu'ils soient y
compris des projets ferroviaires et à
l'exception des projets qui concernaient
le réseau de la voie d'eau
l'évaluation rigoureuse du potentiel de
décarbonation était parfois oublié dans
les projets et ça paraît
particulièrement
étonnant aujourd'hui mais visiblement ça
n'est pas un réflexe qui a été pris de
façon systématique or c'est un criblage
qui au moins aussi important que le
criblage financier désormais puisqu'il
permet lui aussi de prendre des
décisions
de priorisation et la capacité à évoluer
à évaluer pardon elle doit aussi
progresser en matière de résilience des
infrastructures on a abordé ce sujet
calamarge mais on le voit à travers
l'exemple précis de les effets du
changement climatique par exemple sur le
la partie du réseau ferroviaire qui est
la plus immédiatement visible c'est à
dire sur la voie on est encore très loin
de ce qu'on pourrait souhaiter en
matière d'évaluation de la résilience de
nos infrastructures et là aussi ça peut
apparaître comme un effet de de surprise
deux points de vigilance encore avant de
donner la parole à Bruno cavanier sur le
sujet des financements
on a beaucoup concentré la lecture du
rapport sur le transport de voyageurs
or une partie très significative du
rapport est au transport de marchandises
sur lequel aujourd'hui
des éléments de fragilité apparaissent
notamment sur la timide relance du frais
de ferroviaire avec la l'augmentation de
la part modale l'année dernière à 10,6%
contre 9% précédemment
et sur le sur le fluvial on nous
formulons notamment des des
recommandations assez fortes sur
l'accélération ou en tout cas la tenue
des délais et des engagements qui ont
été pris sur l'ensemble des aménagements
prévus sur cdesco parce que là on tient
pour le coup un potentiel de
décarbonation qui est qui est massif
mais donc ça n'est pas un
ce rapport n'est pas un rapport qui ne
concerne que le transport de voyageurs
je tiens à y insister on sera j'imagine
en capacité d'en reparler ensuite
quel que soit les sujets que vous
voudrez aborder et puis
j'insisterai aussi sur dans les messages
du rapport au delà des réponses qui ont
été formulées par la première ministre
en montant sur
sur le ferroviaire et qui sont
significatives
puisque au moins aussi
ce qui est au moins aussi important que
le montant de 100 milliards qui a été
évoqué dans lequel effectivement le la
part des uns et des autres restera à
préciser je n'ai pas de
d'éléments plus précis que ceux que vous
avez vous-même sur la manière dont ce
sera ventilé
mais quoi qu'il arrive nous savons tous
que la part des différents financeurs
devra être augmentés et quand on parle
d'un effort de l'État qui pourrait être
d'à peu près un tiers de cette somme ça
représente déjà beaucoup plus que ce qui
est fait aujourd'hui en effort annuel et
ce qui est à fortiorise qui était fait
il y a il y a encore 5 10 ou 20 ans et
il faut y insister et il faut y insister
et ce qui est au moins aussi important
que ce chiffre de 100 milliards sur le
ferroviaire est globalement que les
montants que nous avons évoqués encore
une fois j'ai insisté la pérennité
des efforts qui sont nécessaires et
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à
recommander à souhaiter là aussi ça fait
l'objet d'un large accord au sein de du
conseil que une loi de programmation
puisse venir décliner ses objectifs
même si je crois que les hésitations
monsieur le Président Longeot vous avez
détaillé avec la subtilité que nous vous
connaissons
ces hésitations sont plus dues à aux
équilibres des forces actuelles à
l'Assemblée nationale et à parfois sur
les sujets d'infrastructures ce qui
s'apparente à une forme de jeu de dupe
ou on aura beau jeu de pointer que une
partie de l'effort sera fait par
d'autres acteurs que l'État
alors que ce qu'il faudrait regarder
c'est l'augmentation de la part de
l'État dans la des financements des
infrastructures par rapport à ce qui
était fait auparavant et tout le monde
sait qu'elle sera plus importante
mais donc il n'y avait que des acteurs
de bonne foi dans les laboration de la
loi je pense qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'hésitation mais je le dis ici avec
beaucoup de liberté
mais ces hésitations elles sont surtout
liées à ce paramètre politique peut-être
Bruno sur le sujet du financement
ensuite je répondrais assez vite aux
interrogations avant d'entendre les deux
rapporteurs
merci de votre invitation bon David
ayant quasiment tout dit je dirais juste
de d'abord David a parlé de la
composition et de la philosophie de ce
rapport et j'insiste là-dessus parce que
vraiment on a regardé plutôt ce qui nous
rapprochait que ce qui nous éloignait ce
qui nous a permis effectivement de nous
mettre quasiment tous d'accord sur ce
rapport est vraiment dans le sens de
l'intérêt général alors il est
probablement pas parfait il y a
probablement des choses à améliorer
probablement quand on regarde les
projets chacun trouve que ça ne va pas
assez vite moi le premier David disait
il y en a dans cette salle qui prenait
le scénario tout infrastructure mais
quand même quand on regarde les
propositions financières que l'on a fait
je crois qu'il y a on parle de beaucoup
d'argent et regarder le dernier rapport
que nous avions fait il y a quelques
années on était souvent les scénarios à
peine à la moitié alors vous allez me
dire les financeurs ne sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes et c'est vrai mais
aujourd'hui il y a énormément d'argent
sur la table
effectivement
le financement et la clé de voûte avec
et tu as raison de le dire le fait il va
falloir faire
et pour faire il faut avoir de la
visibilité tant pour les finances que
pour la partie technique et là si je
prends mon autre casquette de FNTP on a
besoin dans les 10 ans dans les 20 ans
de savoir ce qu'on va avoir à faire en
termes de d'infrastructures et
manifestement on voit bien aujourd'hui
qu'on arrive peu au proue au bout d'un
système
alors on a trouvé des sociétés de
projets qui marchent très bien à Paris
et tant mieux d'ailleurs parce que sinon
je pense qu'on n'aurait pas eu les JO si
tous les ans
les assemblées avaient dû décider de
combien on mettait
on a réussi sur le GPS ou ailleurs à
faire d'autres sociétés de projet mais
on voit bien que ça ne marche pas
partout on voit bien que sur le
versement mobilité on arrive là aussi
à
un maximum que des entreprises ou le
monde économique aura du mal à accepter
même si à titre personnel je défends
énormément le versement mobilité on voit
bien que sur la fit
on arrive aussi à des réflexions comment
financer la fuite avec notamment la
tradition de la TICPE
ou la redevance domaniale bref il y a un
questionnement
et plus comme questionnement il y a
reposé le financement à mon sens des
infrastructures et David le disait
évidemment si on n'a pas une loi de
programmation plus réelle nous n'y
arriverons pas on peut parler de la fin
des sociétés d'autoroute aussi ou tout
le monde se dit on va avoir une manne
extraordinaire bon nous sommes un peu
plus réservés là-dessus et en tous les
cas il faut imaginer des choses alors
tout à l'heure je sais pas c'était le
président rénal qui demanderait est-ce
que on est sûr qu'on va voir cet argent
qu'a dit le ministre des Finances
vous avez la réponse ou l'Économie des
Finances quand le rapport est déposé au
mois de décembre et que deux mois plus
tard on avait toujours pas de réponse
vous pouvez imaginer qu'ils n'ont pas
été emballés par le fait que nous ayons
fait plusieurs scénarios et ce qui
montre bien d'ailleurs que c'est pas le
ce n'est pas le rapport du gouvernement
c'est le rapport du coi
qui est encore une fois essayé d'être
vraiment dans l'intérêt général mais
pour et je finirai là-dessus pour qu'on
arrive à financer ces 100 milliards
d'euros pour qu'on arrive à financer
tous les problématiques d'eau pour qu'on
arrive à financer ce qu'on est en train
de voir sur le nucléaire et la politique
énergétique quand vous mettez
tout ça côte à côte vous vous dites que
ça fait des milliards voire des
centaines de milliards et avec notre
système actuel de financement si on ne
remet pas les choses sur la table si
tout le monde ne se met pas autour de la
table parce que évidemment c'est pas que
l'État qui va y arriver c'est l'État et
les collectivités locales alors espérons
que dans ce pays nous aurons une
réflexion collective et qu'on arrivera à
trouver les financements nécessaires
pour financer toutes ces infrastructures
de régénération ou nouvelle pour
certaines
ce qui est ce que ce que Bruno a dit
avec avec la clarté qui lui est
coutumière c'est que en matière
d'infrastructure le les à-coups sont au
moins autant à craindre que les
sous-financement
je pense que c'est vraiment un des
messages centraux du rapport alors juste
sur le l'un des points sur lesquels j'ai
pas répondu monsieur le Président rénal
sur le plutôt président lonjo pardon sur
le lion Turin et Pierre-Alain peut-être
tout à l'heure dans les réponses qui qui
pourraient être faites aux questions
pourra compléter
ce que le Conseil dit c'est très
exactement ce que le Conseil avait déjà
écrit en 2018
à peu de choses près
à savoir que on est sur un projet dans
le potentiel de décarbonation est
important
qui repose sur une évaluation de la du
report modal et de la croissance du
trafic qui est
très très avancé on peut dire comme ça
qui est un projet transnational et
désormais que on peut considérer que le
coût du tunnel de base est parti
le sujet principal c'est tout simplement
de faire accéder des trains dans un
tunnel et de faire accéder de façon à ne
pas être complètement ridicule par
rapport à la capacité de ce tunnel
le Conseil a considéré que sa
responsabilité était de rappeler
en termes temporel quel était la
priorisation
qui permet de faire tout simplement
circuler des trains dans ce tunnel de
base
et notamment le contournement
ferroviaire de Lyon sur la partie nord
le saint-fon Grenet et je dirais que ça
n'est qu'après qu'on aborde le sujet de
voix nouvelle ou Dijon Modane dans un
premier temps or le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que sur les deux premiers
dossiers qu'on a évoqué que j'ai évoqué
à l'instant on n'a pas le sentiment
qu'il y a eu des bougies très
significatifs et donc ça paraît à tout
le moins préoccupant quand le débat
public se concentre sur une étape de la
fonctionnalité d'une infrastructure qui
n'est pas une étape nécessaire
et que sur les étapes nécessaires on a
le sentiment que ça n'avance pas il y a
de quoi être un peu interrogatif et
c'est ce qu'on a transcrit dans ce
rapport maintenant sur le sujet voie
nouvelle ou Dijon Modane nous ce qu'on
constate simplement et là aussi un sujet
de capacité à faire y compris sur le
plan financier et du débat public et des
procédures c'est que
la dans les circulations sur le la voie
historique Dijon Modane qui se ferait
donc dans un premier temps de la du
fonctionnement du tunnel
elle permettrait de capter plus de 60%
du trafic qui est aujourd'hui espéré
ce qui est loin d'être ridicule
parfois quand on évoque cette cette
étape là on nous oppose que ce serait
complètement
ridicule que ça correspondrait à des
trafics très petits par rapport à la
capacité du tunnel ça n'est pas vrai
et y compris par rapport au tonnage
actuellement constaté tout mode confondu
on serait sur une augmentation très
significative une captation presque
totale des flux ce qui est là aussi très
très ambitieux voilà donc les
recommandations qu'on formule elles ont
pour but d'alerter sur le calendrier de
ce projet ou encore une fois le débat
public se concentre sur des un débat sur
les infrastructures nouvelles ou pas
alors même que les sujets de
fonctionnalités de base pour faire
fonctionner le tunnel aujourd'hui nous
semble avoir peu avancé et de réalisme
sur la capacité à faire sur le plan
financier et
administratif et technique pour tout
simplement faire circuler des trains de
fret dans ce tunnel dans le calendrier
qui est aujourd'hui envisagé
merci merci Président Monsieur
vice-président j'ai peut-être mon
distribué la parole et je vais donner la
parole à Philippe Tabarro et puis
monsieur le rapporteur général du coi
vous interviendrez dans le cadre du
débat merci Messieurs les Présidents les
rapporteurs mais mes chers collègues moi
je suis ravi cher David de te retrouver
au Sénat avec mes collègues du
développement durable et des Finances
alors il y a des rencontres ce matin
entre députés sénateurs qui sont plus
médiatisés que la nôtre mais je pense
que la nôtre est tout aussi intéressante
moi je suis ravi en tant que membre du
coi et avec mes excellents collègues
Herzog et Dagbert représentant notre
assemblée
ravi aussi parce qu'avec David et avec
Pierre Alain nous avons dans mes
précédentes fonctions de vice-président
de région en charge des transports sucré
des liens de confiance c'est dans cet
esprit que nous avons travaillé à ce
rapport je veux témoigner de l'ampleur
et de la qualité du travail réalisé je
vais également saluer l'esprit
d'indépendance et ça a été souligné qui
a été le vôtre par rapport à la commande
politique et au cadrage budgétaire
initial
ainsi que l'esprit de liberté dont on
peut jouir les différents membres pour
faire entendre leur priorité ou leur
nuances
je me félicite aussi dans cet esprit
qu'avec l'acceptation du président
Valence en gros entre Noël et le jour de
l'an d'avoir pu intégrer une
contribution que j'ai porté avec Louis
et Christine erzog et qui a été
annexé au rapport une contribution qui
défend plus de moyens pour les
transports ferroviaires du quotidien
sans stigmatiser les LGV qui peuvent
désenclaver ou développer certains
territoires LGV n'est pas un gros mot
dans notre vocabulaire ça a été il y a
quelques années et ça doit le rester la
fierté de la France
et puis également
notamment celle qui ont été annoncées
par un précédent Premier ministre qui a
pris un certain nombre d'engagement sur
ces sujets de plus je ne me résous pas
d'abandonner des projets routiers qui
peuvent participer à leur pertinence à
décongestionner des territoires ne
donnons pas l'impression de dresser les
modes de transport les uns contre les
autres
en fait nous avons souhaité exprimer nos
inquiétudes et ça a été abordé sur la
livraison du lion Turin dont parlera
également je le sais mon collègue
Étienne blanc et du respect des
engagements internationaux de la France
tout cela dans un scénario qu'on
pourrait appeler de plus et que nous
appelons toujours de nos vœux
alors mes questions vont être très
directes et très simple et ne concerne
bien sûr pas le rapport mais sont
devenus
premièrement quelle garantie pour que
l'État tiennent ces engagements de 100
milliards d'ici 2040
deuxièmement vous y avez répondu en
partie et on est bien sûr d'accord ici
au Sénat sur votre réponse quel véhicule
législatif pour cet engagement pour
qu'il soit inscrit dans le temps et soit
surtout irréversible ça a été dit le
ferroviaire et le transport en général
ne supporte pas des arrêts brutaux sur
certains projets la machine est trop
difficile à remettre en route ensuite la
part de l'État n'est-elle pas
insuffisante alors vous allez me dire
c'est 25 milliards monsieur le président
de la commission des finances je sais
que ce n'est pas suffisant mais ça
représente qu'un quart au final par
rapport à la part des autres partenaires
et notamment celle des collectivités
territoriales
que pensez-vous de la mise sous tutelle
entre guillemets de SNCF réseau par la
Société du Grand Paris notamment pour la
mise en place des réseaux express
métropolita en fin n'est-il pas urgent
de revoir le contrat de performance qui
devient de fait obsolètes si la première
ministre daigne respecter sa parole
merci Philippe alors nous allons avoir
les quatre rapports qui vont s'exprimer
en premier donc Hervé Hervé Moret puis
Hervé
merci monsieur le Président merci
Messieurs les Présidents d'avoir
organisé cette réunion qui nous paraît
très utile à Stéphane sautard elle est à
moi-même j'aurais bien sûr saluer le la
qualité du travail du coi et de la
présentation qui nous a été faite ce
matin et dire qu'on se réjouit plutôt
des conclusions du coi parce que ça ça
rejoint beaucoup de de conclusions et de
préconisations qu'on a nous-mêmes
exprimé que ce soit dans notre rapport
de l'année dernière sur le ferroviaire
ou dans nos différents rapports dans le
cadre de l'élaboration des lois de
finances nous avons eu l'occasion avec
Stéphane sotorel de réagir aux annonces
de la première ministre on nous
réjouissant de ce qui semble être une
prise de conscience de sa part mais en
nous inquiétant du fait que ce qui
semble être une prise de conscience
n'est à ce stade pas accompagné d'un
plan de financement puisque ça a été dit
je crois par un président Longeot il y a
à peine un tiers de financement de
l'État en termes d'annonce à ce stade et
sans un calendrier puisqu'on nous on
nous évoque des choses à échéance de de
ce quinquennat et je crois d'ailleurs
que depuis on a précisé que le scénario
2 n'était qu'un point de qu'un point de
départ et qu'a priori ça n'était pas non
plus
le dogme auquel le gouvernement semblait
se s'attacher
l'album ça a été rappelé prévoit que la
trajectoire financière doit être révisée
avant le 30 juin 2023 c'est-à-dire très
prochainement et je crois que ça a été
également exprimé on ne sait pas comment
cette trajectoire va être révisée on n'a
pas d'assurance qu'on aura une loi
d'orientation des mobilités enfin un
nouveau texte de programmation président
Valence a l'air de d'excuser par avance
le fait qu'il n'y ait pas un tel un tel
texte j'avoue que de notre point de vue
ce serait ce serait regrettable et quand
vous dites monsieur le Président qu'on
met beaucoup plus d'argent qu'avant je
dirais d'abord heureusement parce que
dans la période notamment 2012-2017 on
en a mis très peu et que de surcroît on
sait bien que moi on met d'argent plus
par la suite il faut en rajouter on dit
souvent quand on met pas un euro
aujourd'hui on en met 10 à terme et je
rappellerai d'ailleurs que le Sénat
était le premier dès 2017 à organiser
une table ronde sur la question de la
dégradation des infrastructures plus
clair et attirer un peu la sonnette
d'alarme sur sur ce sujet donc moi je
voudrais Stéphane souterral interviendra
ensuite mais je voudrais surtout vous
interroger sur la question du du
ferroviaire
parce que
le la première ministre a annoncé qu'en
terme de modernisation aujourd'hui rien
n'est prévu dans le contrat dit des
performances mais que nous nous
préferons appeler le contrat de
contre-performance qui est un contrat
Mornet donc la première ministre a
annoncé 500 millions par an c'est
formidable mais nous on considère qu'il
faut 35 milliards donc on va moderniser
le réseau sur 70 ans première question
deuxième question on a appelé à une
refonte totale du mode de financement
des infrastructures ferroviaires je
crois que vous-même vous avez émis des
réserves sur la question de la
tarification de l'infrastructure est-ce
que vous êtes allé un petit peu au-delà
sur ce qu'il conviendrait de faire pour
revoir ce financement aux
infrastructures je rappellerai que les
péages vont augmenter de 8% cette année
en moyenne que ça pèse pour 40% dans le
prix du billet donc ça va encore se
répercuter sur l'usager et tout cela
confirme le fait qu'à notre avis il
faudrait vraiment revoir profondément le
financement des infrastructures
ferroviaires et donc moi j'aimerais bien
avoir vos remarques vos suggestions et
vos propositions en la matière et puis
dernier mot vous avez assisté sur le
fait qu'il fallait donner priorité à la
à la régénération que ce soit en domaine
ferroviaire ou dans le domaine routier
je crois me souvenir que le précédent
rapport du coi avait dit exactement la
même chose et puis qu'un beau jour on a
eu des effets d'annonce sur des lignes
nouvelles alors je sais que ça ne
déplaît pas au vice-président mais voilà
il faut peut-être aussi avoir un peu de
cohérence on peut pas dire la priorité
c'est ça et puis on changeait en cours
de route
merci je vais donner la parole à Hervé
gilet
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur je vous ai écouté avec beaucoup
de détention et votre découpement
démontre la nécessité s'il en était
encore besoin de définir une vision de
long terme en matière d'infrastructure
de transport et il s'agit assurément
d'une politique du temps long qui
nécessite de définir des priorités
claires des objectifs partagés entre les
différents acteurs concernés avant
d'engager des investissements souvent
colossaux donc votre travail est un
travail de qualité j'apporterai juste un
petit bémol quand même dans la méthode
dans la manière dont ça peut être perçu
à l'extérieur puisque vous avez rendu
votre document fin décembre et puis
après vous savez il y a eu beaucoup de
rhumes de scénario de réécriture et
derrière ces rumeurs laissent ça laisse
planer le fait qu'il y a toujours des
pressions politiques qui sont organisées
pour avoir effectivement un document
final donc il faut quand même le dire il
faut quand même le souligner j'imagine
qu'au travers de l'ensemble de vos
membres c'est loin d'être le cas et je
suis pers qu'il y a eu une intégrité
vraiment totale dans l'écriture mais il
fallait quand même l'indiquer puisque ce
sujet existe il faut pas le balayer
simplement d'un revers de la main il
impératif sans doute de rechercher la
plus grande cohérence aujourd'hui entre
les priorités définies au niveau local
entre les différents niveaux de
collectivité je vais y revenir mais
aussi entre le niveau local et le niveau
national et le rapport du coi souligne
d'ailleurs les difficultés liées ici là
la juxtaposition de contrat de schéma de
protocole de convention qui ne sont pas
toujours cohérents entre eux et cette
situation pose souvent problème d'une
situation importante dans le cadre de la
vie budgétaire sur les transports
routiers j'ai eu le plaisir de rapporter
que j'ai eu le plaisir de rapporter au
nom de la commission j'ai par exemple pu
constater à quel point le manque de
coordination entre les agglomérations
métropoles les communes périphériques
pouvaient être dommageables et infinie
entraver notre capacité collective à
répondre aux besoins de mobilité de nos
concitoyens donc dans ce contexte
estimez-vous nécessaire de revoir ou pas
la gouvernance elle-même mais la
déclinaison concrète de cette compétence
mobilité dans les différents schémas de
planification on voit que ces schémas
sont souvent manquants il y a un manque
aujourd'hui d'organisation territoriale
et permet absolument je souhaiterais une
intégration notamment aussi dans les
documents d'urbanisme manière plus
volontaire et dans les scottes
intégrateurs qui participeraient aussi
de vision partagée et puis à ce titre le
report modal l'intermodalité sont
souvent enfin sont insuffisamment
considérés et notamment les coûts
annexes en fait parce que quand on
regarde bien sur les politiques
d'aménagement et d'infrastructures les
coûts sont souvent sous-estimés et c'est
quand même un sujet qui est
particulièrement important donc derrière
cette question de planification et de
compétences se pose la question bien sûr
du financement donc la dernière partie
de votre rapport traite de la
sécurisation du modèle économique des
transports en commun recommandent
d'identifier de nouvelles sources de
financement à la fois pour l'entretien
le développement d'inf mais aussi pour
leur exploitation l'exemple du Grand
Paris Express dont le montage financier
est toujours pas finalisé est à ce
regard quand même édifiant même si il y
a une solidité qui nous paraît
effectivement intéressantes mais la
maîtrise de l'endettement reste pointée
nous devons absolument anticiper cette
question dans ce que lorsque nous aurons
à parler des futurs RER métropolitains
et donc ça a été souligné sur certaines
prises de parole est-ce que vous
soutenez l'évolution de l'offre de
service d'ailleurs du Grand Paris
Express venant en soutien sur de la
délégation à maîtrise d'ouvrage pour
mettre en place le RER métropolitain
mais la deuxième question n'est pas sans
doute les attributions du coi mais je
souhaiterais avoir votre idée votre avis
sur l'idée de faire évoluer notamment au
bénéfice des zones peu denses les
perceptions la perception des recettes
du versement mobilité ce débat nous
avait beaucoup mobilisé même divisé
l'occasion de l'examen du projet de loi
de finance pour 2023 cette question elle
est toujours pas réglée et quand on
prend la compétence transport et qu'on
en pas les moyens ça sert pas à grand
chose et si on veut faire véritablement
une inter modalité ça pose quand même
question et puis quand on parle de la
société de financement je ne peux pas en
tant que Girondins de parvenir sur le
GPSO quand même rapidement juste j'ai
bien compris que on est dans l'esprit de
la loi l'homme au niveau du calendrier
mais par rapport aux annonces
précédentes nous annonce précédentes
voulaient accélérer donc il y a 2 ans de
report quand même sur Bordeaux Toulouse
il y aurait un report après le
quinquennat de Bordeaux Dax qui remettra
en question quand même la question du
financement européen donc c'est pas une
petite question cette affaire là donc ça
mérite peut-être quelques
éclaircissements je ne doute pas que
vous allez les apporter enfin mon
dernier point portera sur les
infrastructures routières qui sont
peut-être un peu effectivement moins
prise en considération pourrait-on dire
dans votre rapport et ce qui a été
souligné par le ministre Clément baume
qui considère que le scénario de la
planification pose question puisqu'il
réduit beaucoup peut-être un peu trop
les investissements sur la route donc on
peut considérer que là il y a une
variable d'ajustement bud
à ce niveau là et donc l'augmentation du
prix de l'énergie des matériaux
notamment sur les fameuses routes
nationales éventuellement concédées aux
collectivités volontaires là ça craint
n'a désengagement de l'État sur le
réseau routier dont l'état laisse déjà
désiré ce que vous partagez ces
inquiétudes avez-vous pris en compte ces
éléments de contexte dans la définition
des scénarios et puis vous n'avez pas
proposé des scénarios post concession
autoroutières quel est votre avis sur le
sujet comment appréhendez-vous donc on
l'a dit il faudrait y revenir les
annonces de la première ministre sur la
mise à contribution du secteur notamment
autoroutier et puisque je suis girondin
la question de l'acceptabilité est une
question quand même aujourd'hui très
très importante il faut bien la peser et
la souplesse un petit exemple sur la
mise à trois voies de l'A63 pour se
brancher sur la rocade avec une
concession autoroutière ça va être un
sujet qui va être compliqué pour tout
vous dire véritablement sur une
concession autoroutière compte tenu de
l'information qui circule aujourd'hui
sur les dites concessions aujourd'hui
voilà ce que je voulais vous souligner
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci Hervé Stéphane Sautarel pour
terminer l'expression de nos rapporteurs
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues je vais
essayer d'être bref pour laisser la
possibilité à mes collègues de poser des
questions sur un sujet qui suscite
l'intérêt de beaucoup je vais simplement
dans le droit fil de ce qu'a pu dire
déjà Hervé Moret au nom de la commission
des finances revenir sur les sujets
essentiellement de financement de
lisibilité de financement de pérennité
de financement que vous avez évoqué et
sur la manière dont vous abordez
les réformes en profondeur de ce système
de financement que certaines pistes sont
proposées notamment au niveau au niveau
fiscal mais qui renvoie également vous
l'avez dit à des co-financement soit de
collectivités territoriales soit des
financements européens et et je voulais
insister sur une dimension là notamment
sur l'accès au financement européen ça a
déjà été évoqué par rapport à des
calendriers par rapport à des
engagements aussi de la France en la
matière qui peuvent être qui peuvent
être interrogés alors que c'est
incontestablement une voix qui doit nous
permettre notamment sur tout ce qui
touche à la modernisation de notre
réseau puisque la France a été qualifiée
comme le le point faible ou le point
noir du réseau européen ferroviaire
notamment sur tout ce qui touche aux
commandes centralisées et à l'etms donc
incontestablement on a à la fois dés
exigences et des obligations en la
matière et donc j'aimerais savoir
comment comment vous vous l'aborder de
même sur la question des péages où là
aussi si on fait des comparaisons
européennes la situation de la France
est quand même particulière en tout cas
relativement différente de nos grands
voisins qui ont su à la fois moderniser
investir et investir dans la durée
effectivement vous avez insisté c'est
quasiment majeur la visibilité que l'on
peut donner sur sur la durée au niveau
des investissements dans ces dans ces
infrastructures qui appellent qui
nécessitent le temps long et non pas la
remise en cause et c'était une des
raisons et je me réjouis du rapport que
vous avez rendu de l'attente que nous
avions de ce rapport-là puisqu'on ne
cessait de nous répondre que nous étions
dans l'attente le gouvernement était
dans l'attente des des propositions du
coi pour nous donner des éléments dans
le PLF et et donc nous désespérons de
pouvoir enfin examiner un PLF après le
le rapport du coi est dont je me réjouis
que pour beaucoup il rejoignent des
éléments qu'on avait pu avancer et donc
ma deuxième question toujours sur ce
financement c'est sur les collectivités
territoriales puisque nous lançons par
ailleurs au niveau de la commission des
finances une mission d'information sur
le financement des Awen qui préoccupe
beaucoup aujourd'hui et au-delà des
infrastructures on sait que la question
c'est aussi le matériel roulant c'est le
niveau de service et si ces mêmes
collectivités sont appelées et
mobilisées à la fois sur le matériel
roulant en tant qu'a OM et que par
ailleurs l'État pense à elle très
fortement pour co-financer les
investissements on peut s'interroger sur
la soutenabilité de ce modèle là du coup
je rejoins assez grandement ce que vous
avez posé comme question et notamment
Bruno cavanier aussi sur le nouveau
système à réinventer et de ce point de
vue là ce qui peut
provenir du modèle de la SGP en
particulier avec sans doute des
modalités revues mais mais élargi dans
un lien de nouveau avec SNCF réseau que
moi je vois plutôt positivement
puisqu'on interrogeait aussi dans notre
rapport sur la nécessité de
d'autonomiser SNCF réseau qui
aujourd'hui est en grande partie qui a
une victime du mode de financement de de
la holding SNCF et donc si sur ces
modèles là effectivement il peut y avoir
une nouvelle approche
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur pour vos interventions
respectives
les enjeux du fret de marchandises ne
semble pas avoir été suffisamment pris
en compte dans ce rapport mettez-moi de
le dire directement pourtant la
décarbonation des flux et de la
logistique du fret et crucial pour
assurer un système de mobilité plus
vertueux les acteurs du secteur sont
engagés vous le savez dans une stratégie
à long terme en faveur de la transition
écologique du fret par voie fluviale
maritime et ferroviaire vous avez évoqué
rapidement président Valence à la fin de
votre intervention le fluvial cela peut
notamment se faire grâce à un réseau
pertinent de plateformes multimodal
capable de capter et centraliser une
plus large échelle des flux de
marchandises importants on en a beaucoup
parlé d'ailleurs lors de la mission
d'information animée par les rapporteurs
Nicole Bonnefoy et Rémy Pointreau le
développement de ces plateformes
accusent aujourd'hui un retard très
important en France ce qui nuit à la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et de
nos grands ports maritimes français ces
projets d'in
[Musique]
attentes en matière de contribution du
secteur aérien merci
merci Monsieur rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Président d'abord je
voudrais comme les présidents
souhaitaient la bienvenue aux membres du
CIO mais plus pratiquement à son
président David qui est un voisin et un
ami qui est un Lorrain et ben oui ça
fait beaucoup de bonnes choses et de
bonnes nouvelles ce matin
[Rires]
voilà donc tout ça se
je voudrais
vraiment très rapidement premier élément
je
avoir le nombre de collègues présents je
crois que le sujet des
transports déplacements mobilité est un
sujet majeur qui nécessiterait me
semble-t-il un plan au moins décennale
de remise à niveau et d'adaptation
puisque beaucoup a été dit sur le
ferroviaire moi sur le fluvial qui reste
un sujet notamment
sur certains canaux
et concernant plus patiemment le
transport le fret j'aurai aussi dire et
insister sur la dégradation inquiétante
du réseau routier en général le réseau
routier national il se trouve que moi
dans le Grand Est quand je prends le
réseau routier national j'ai
régulièrement des pancartes qui
m'indiquent attention trou en formation
5000 mètres ça s'arrête pendant un
kilomètre et ça continue à chaque fois
mais c'est aussi la même chose sur le
réseau routier départemental c'est un
peu égal et malheureusement sur le
réseau routier communal je le redis
devant tout le monde parce que je crois
que c'est une alerte comment voulez-vous
que nos compatriotes ne n'est pas un
sentiment de déclassement quand il ne
bénéficie pas d'un réseau routier
entretenu en bon état pour se rendre
dans leur territoire c'est leur mode de
déplacement unique lorsqu'ils sont
éloignés des villes et des
agglomérations
et je le redis ils ont le sentiment
d'une forme d'oubli deux questions la
première elle rejoint d'ailleurs ce qu'a
dit Stéphane sotarel et c'est pas un
gros mot puisque ça touche la LGV
notamment effectivement la part qui
concerne qui est de l'ordre de 20% des
subventions européennes qui semblent-ils
sont restés hypothétiques
qu'elle vision qu'elles assurances ou
qu'elle garantit
vous disposez actuellement parce que si
il y a de la fragilité ça veut dire que
le modèle pourrait être remis en cause
donc c'est à mon avis une préoccupation
et la deuxième question qui touche là
encore à la prolongation de la ligne E
du RER le fameux projet Éole
qui pourrait donc être pris en charge
par l'État à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros mais ça a été évoqué notamment
dans son propos par David Valence sur
une dépense à laquelle pourrait
participer la Société du Grand Paris
est-ce que ça voudrait dire que dans ce
cas il lui faudrait recourir de son côté
une nouvelle source de financement pour
assurer cette charge nouvelle et dans ce
cas laquelle
merci je vais dans la parole à Nicole
Bonnefoy
criant du rapport du CIO à savoir celui
de la ligne ferroviaire Angoulême
Limoges fermé depuis 5 ans j'ai été
frappé de ce manque de considération
pour cette ligne si essentielle pour nos
connexions interdépartementales pourtant
ce n'est pas faute d'engagement répété
de la première ministre plaidant pour la
préservation des petites lignes du
quotidien encore celui du précédent
ministre des Transports signant avec la
région nouvelle-aquitaine le protocole
pour les petites lignes de demain qui
mentionnaient très clairement la ligne
Angoulême Limoges dans le cadre des
contrats de plan est à région aussi que
devons-nous conclure du silence
assourdissant du rapport du CIO comment
justifier vous le retrait de l'État sur
cette ligne qui pourtant a fait l'objet
d'une attention constante et de
promesses réitérer cette évolution est
inacceptable au regard des engagements
du gouvernement le 3 mars dernier le
ministre des Transports les montbonnes a
confirmé une nouvelle fois le souhait de
rouvrir cette ligne à ce stade la
végétation pousse au milieu des rails
SNCF réseau indique pourtant que des
études préliminaires sont en cours avec
des résultats attendus dans le courant
de l'année 2023 afin de définir les
travaux à réaliser et une première
enveloppe l'objectif infini étant de
rouvrir la ligne cependant le silence
dont vous faites preuve dans ce rapport
sur cette ligne pourtant soutenue par
l'ensemble des territoires concernés est
étonnant de mon point de vue comment le
justifier vous par ailleurs je suis
honoré de figurer dans votre rapport en
tant que contributrice sur la question
de la plateforme de transport combiné de
Cognac plateforme de fret ferroviaire à
l'arrêt plateforme neuve les l'industrie
d'iconiaque préférant utiliser la route
que le rail sujet encore simplement
mentionné sans plus de précision alors
que vous préconisez un report modal vers
le ferroviaire pour le trafic des
marchandises en dernier lieu le rapport
évoque certains problèmes de report de
poids lourd sur les axes dépourvus de
péage en indiquant que ceux-ci sont
souvent inférieurs aux prévisions pour
les sections dont le pH est trop élevé
je suis en totale des accords avec cette
insertion et je vous invite à considérer
le report de trafic poids lourd de
l'autoroute A10 vers la route nationale
10 entre Poitiers et Bordeaux qui
engendre des nuisances exponentielles
d'ailleurs le rapport précise bien que
le trafic des poids lourds progresse
encore si je salue la volonté du coi de
développer le frais de ferviaire il faut
aujourd'hui donner aux élus la
possibilité de restreindre de manière
temporaire le trafic poids lourd j'ai
d'ailleurs moi-même déposé une
proposition de loi en ce sens afin de
lutter contre le phénomène de report car
rendu notre route nationale extrêmement
accidentogène et impraticable pour les
véhicules légers les autoroutes
aujourd'hui concédaient sont en capacité
de réguler ce trafic grâce à une
politique de péage dynamique pour
diminuer les congestions à l'oeuvre dans
nos métropoles
j'aurais aimé voir une recommandation du
coi portant sur ce point noir qui
concerne non seulement la Charente mais
bien d'autres territoires laissant les
élus captifs de leurs infrastructures je
vous remercie pour votre écoute et vos
réponses
mais merci Nicole d'avoir respecté les
deux minutes
une question brève monsieur le Président
puisque nous examinons actuellement le
zéro artificialisation net de ce que
tout cela est compatible avec des
objectifs de sobriété foncière
merci très bonne question à un sujet
d'actualité et la parole
merci monsieur le Président et ma
question porte sur le lion Turin
elle s'articule autour de
quatre sous questions si l'on peut dire
la déclaration d'utilité publique et qui
va permettre et faciliter les voies
d'accès au tunnel de base arrive à
échéance en 2028
et on ne nous a pas parlé
de cette déclaration d'utilité publique
pour être clair la question est-ce que
aujourd'hui le conseil de natation des
infrastructures peut imaginer laisser
tomber cette DUP avec toutes les
conséquences que cela emportera pour
l'avenir de la réalisation de ces voies
d'accès madame question c'est l'Italie
vous n'avez pas cité l'Italie on a le
sentiment que le COI a établi un rapport
franco-français alors même que le lion
Turin fait l'objet d'un accord avec
l'Italie je le rappelle très brièvement
l'Italie a surfinancé le tunnel de base
de 10 % par rapport à la France parce
que l'Italie avait moins de voies
d'accès
aujourd'hui l'Italie financera est
respectera ses engagements et la France
ne respecte pas ses engagements sur les
voies d'accès nous sommes dans un accord
international c'est un manquement de la
parole française est-ce que le COI a
mesuré les conséquences que cela aura
dans nos rapports avec l'Italie
quatrième question c'est l'Europe
troisième question bah on sait l'Europe
l'Europe a clairement manifesté le fait
qu'elle n'acceptait pas que le lion
Turin devienne un disjon Turin
ça ne correspond pas à ce qu'elle entend
sur la réalisation de ce grand projet de
connexion et des réseaux européens donc
la troisième question est simple est-ce
que sur ce sujet là le CEIP nous
apporter des précisions qu'elles ont été
qu'elle a été la teneur de ces
discussions et de ses échanges avec leur
quatrième et dernier point on l'a bien
compris pendant des années on nous a
expliqué mais ça n'est pas grave
d'investir sur la ligne Dijon Modane il
faudra de toute façon le faire et en
aucun cas cela ne se substitue au voie
d'accès entre Lyon et Modane puis
aujourd'hui on nous écrit noir sur blanc
que finalement ça permettra de reporter
la réalisation des voies d'accès entre
Lyon et Modane après 2045
et la région de Chambéry explique que ça
va créer une véritable thrombose dans le
bassin chambérien que ça va gêner
considérablement les projets de
développement des RER là aussi est-ce
que le COI a mesuré les conséquences
pour Chambéry et le grand bassin
chambérien de cette préconisation d'un
report à après 2045 et des voies d'accès
merci Étienne Didier Rambaud
merci ça tombe bien c'est aussi une
question sur le lion Turin rappeler
effectivement que en ce moment on est en
train de construire le tunnel
transfrontalier mais que la question des
accès français
sa piétine
et que pendant ce temps le l'Union
européenne s'impatiente parce que
l'Union européenne rappelons-nous sur ce
sujet là est un gros gros financeur
alors c'est vrai que la position du coi
réellement réaffirmant ou disant que
l'hypothèse Dijon amberieu Modane était
une solution disons-le franchement
aujourd'hui crée la panique un petit peu
chez les acteurs économiques et
politiques de Rhône-Alpes peut-être que
nous l'avons un peu cherché
faute d'engagement précis de la part
d'un certain nombre de collectivités
locales donc ma question est très claire
est-ce que ce le choix des accès
français maintenant au tunnel sera lié à
un positionnement clair des
collectivités locales merci
la parole est à Madame Perrot
merci président merci messieurs merci
monsieur le Président pour pour vos
rapports
je voulais vous poser une question sur
l'eau et une sur l'air je crois que
Stéphane demuyer a commencé je vais les
continuer donc sur l'eau nous en avons
parlé en aparté monsieur le Président
il faut il est important de soutenir le
développement des ports intérieurs
multi-modiaux et vous savez que nous en
avons un
en l'espèce du port de Nogent et c'est
un projet d'agrandissement de la zone
portuaire pour utiliser pleinement le
passage à grand gabarit fluvial de la
section Braine Nogent normalement
déclaré d'utilité publique le 22 juillet
dernier les
travaux devraient se
la fin du chantier prévue pour 2028 donc
j'ai besoin d'une confirmation et la
deuxième question sur l'air
effectivement
le comme le souligne votre rapport le
Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures n'a pas été mandaté pour
traiter du transport aérien je souhaite
malgré tout vous interroger sur ce sujet
d'autant plus que le gouvernement a
indiqué le mois dernier que le secteur
serait mis à contribution pour financer
les 100 milliards d'euros qui doivent
être mobilisés pour les infrastructures
ferroviaires d'ici 2040 cette annonce
suscite des inquiétudes auprès des
compagnies aériennes qui sortent comme
vous le savez d'une période de forte
incertitude marquée par un effondrement
des recettes liées à la crise sanitaire
malgré ce contexte difficile le secteur
a déjà remis sa feuille de route
comportant les actions à mettre en
oeuvre pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone à horizon 2050 comme le
prévoyait l'Artic de la loi climat et
résilience comme vous le savez cette
ambition de décarbonation du transport
aérien reposera essentiellement sur un
levier le développement des carburants
durables or à ce jour l'offre de
carburant durable demeure très limité
faute de ville de filière industrielle
suffisamment développée en outre ces
carburants lorsqu'ils seront disponibles
feront l'objet d'un conflit d'usage
important entre les différents secteurs
donc ma question est double premièrement
si notre commission partage largement
l'objectif d'investir massivement dans
la régénération des infrastructures
ferroviaires il faudra être vigilant en
mettant à contribution le secteur aérien
à ne pas trop affaiblir ses capacités à
investir en faveur de la décarbonation
d'autant que ce secteur fait face à une
concurrence internationale très forte
quel regard portez-vous sur ce sujet
avez-vous des précisions à nous apporter
sur de la manière dont le secteur aérien
sera sollicité enfin s'il volait
aéronautique France 2030 consacre plus
d'un milliard d'euros à la recherche et
à l'innovation aéronautique le
développement des carburants durables
semblent faire l'objet de moins de
volontarisme dans notre pays idée vous
des pistes financières pour soutenir
plus amplement la consolidation de cette
filière industrielle je vous remercie
Evelyne Dominati
merci monsieur le président
félicitations pour votre rapport et
heureusement que le Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures
existent parce que vous parlez du temps
long mais au cours du 2 derniers
quinquennat il y a eu 4 ministres sous
François Hollande six sous Emmanuel
Macron
deux ministres des Transports sous
François Hollande trois jumeaux le
président actuel c'est-à-dire un
ministre de la transition écologique
tous les ans en moyenne durée de vie un
ministre des Transports durée de vie
tous les deux ans donc c'est difficile
pour les parlementaires ou pour les élus
locaux d'avoir des interlocuteurs
fiables et de faire en sorte que la
parole publique soit respectée et
entendue puisque les titulaires de ces
postes stratégiques changent
régulièrement durée de vie un an alors
je vous ferai part simplement de mes
inquiétudes ou de mon expérience parce
que je suis depuis quelques temps
séparer et en réalité on a les sociétés
d'État qui font un peu le système des
poupées russes c'est à dire on lance les
projets on donne la signature de l'État
et puis on emprunte voilà comment se
passe depuis très très longtemps dans
notre pays les transports collectifs
c'est-à-dire on crée une société on met
très peu de capital la dernière ce que
vous avez signalé à ce JT du Grand Paris
théoriquement devait avoir 4 milliards
de capital revenant d'aide à l'industrie
automobile ils sont jamais venus donc il
y a simplement la signature de l'État
l'emprunt est en construit la deuxième
caractéristique c'est généralement les
travaux ne sont jamais réalisés dans le
budget les budget double parfois parfois
c'est 50% de plus parfois c'est le
double des travaux
initialement prévu ce qui fait que
compte tenu de l'enveloppe budgétaire
que vous définissez nous savons très
bien que nous pourrons faire que la
moitié des travaux ou qu'il faudra
multiplier le budget
typiquement par deux de selon votre
prévision alors lorsqu'on a ces
perspectives qui sont quand même
inquiétantes à tous les échelons du pays
le problème se pose une financement et
le financement vous l'avez dit il n'est
pas assuré par l'État il n'est
absolument pas assuré par l'État à la
hauteur de ce que font les autres pays
alors des sociétés d'État un état qui ne
finance pas nous sommes dans un site
dans une situation particulièrement
bloquée et j'attendrai moi du corps
d'orientation des infrastructures qu'ils
soient plus sévères sur les surcos parce
que il y a trop d'excès qu'il soit plus
sévères sur la programmation nous
lorsqu'on a eu une Société du Grand
Paris Express nous étions beaucoup de
parlementaires à demander si la liaison
Charles de Gaulle Express Paris faisait
partie du projet tous les ingénieurs
tous les pontes je dirais des grands
ministères des sociétés nous ont
expliqué que donc c'était pas financiers
et qu'il n'y avait pas de viabilité la
société aérienne Air France qui a été
interrogée dit qu'il n'y avait pas de
faisabilité les élus locaux je dirais
dans leur ensemble ont vu à la fois la
prévisation de ce sujet et puis
l'abandon pour absence de rentabilité
financière pour finalement être reprise
par une loi d'exception je dirais
organique pour le lancer théoriquement
pour les Jeux Olympiques et pour les
Jeux Olympiques tout le monde sait que
c'est passé il y a eu la crise du covid
et qu'elle ne sera pas faite voilà un
exemple de la gestion des transports
collectifs en Île de France tels que on
peut la vivre je dirais sur l'expérience
et sur la durée je voulais vous faire
part de cette expérience pour votre
prochain rapport
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole monsieur devinez
[Musique]
merci la parole est à chaque fermic oui
merci monsieur le Président alors c'est
un peu compliqué d'être court sur ce
rapport passionnant un travail collectif
riche dense et quand même limpide alors
justement limpide parce qu'il avance un
scénario de planification écologique ou
quand on y regarde de près le mot
écologique n'est pas là pour faire
sympathique mais est fondé sur la
volonté de tenir nos objectifs de
décarbonation de biodiversité de
freinage de l'artificialisation de
protection de la ressource en eau et
donc souhaite vraiment modifier notre
réponse à nos besoins de transport et de
déplacement au regard de ces impératifs
donc sur la régénération et la
modernisation du rail ce qui est
effectivement j'ai un capital essentiel
vraiment je dirais le mérite fort sur la
modernisation c'est de montrer notre
retard notre décalage au regard de nos
du européen en clair l'objectif européen
pour l'ERTS
c'est 2030 on n'y sera pas toute manière
et je crois que vous dites que en
multipliant par 10 les Forex si on y
arrive en 2040 ça sera déjà formidable
pour les commandes centralisées on en
parlait tout à l'heure ce qui est déjà
réalisé pour l'Allemagne la Belgique la
Suisse je crois nous c'est au rythme
actuel 2060
sur les
l'accélération deuxième axe Ford des
systèmes métropolitains régionaux donc
des fameux REM moi je suis bien placé de
voir que c'est c'est important de
travailler ce que vous disiez sur le
savoir-faire savoir organiser les
difficultés les ratées au démarrage du
Réseau Express métropolitain de
Strasbourg en témoignent sur
l'adaptation et la transition des routes
j'ai effectivement été intéressé par la
remarque forte qu'il ne s'agit plus à
l'avenir de rechercher alors ça c'est
moi qui le rajoute un peu vêtements et
de façon très coûteuse la fluidité d'un
trafic routier toujours plus important
que c'est plus ça qui est en cause dans
la transition à mener des routes et puis
quatrième axe la transition la
trajectoire d'investissement pour la
voie d'eau qui est à tenir alors ma
question trois questions rapidement
c'est comment tenir ses orientations
très claires parce que la proposition
qui est de dire le scénario priorité aux
infrastructures c'est une étagère sur
lequel on piochera dans laquelle on
piochera si on en a les moyens il est
pas question de le réaliser de choisir
ce scénario en bloc donc le scénario de
base on a bien compris centrale c'est
celui de transition écologique
parce que moi je lis ce qui me rassure
la phrase forte du conseil qui dit quel
que soit les sensibilités le Conseil
s'accorde sur l'impériose nécessité de
ne plus sacrifier les programmes au
projet la modernisation de l'existant à
l'engagement d'infras nouvelle mais on
entend déjà aujourd'hui
de tous ceux qui interviennent sur le
lion Turin parce qu'ils y retrouve pas
leur compte par rapport à ce qui rêvait
sur les projets routiers ce que
j'entendais tout à l'heure sur les
points de vigilance sur la la capacité à
évaluer en anticipation plus
rigoureusement l'impact de décarbonation
quand je regarde aujourd'hui qu'on est
en train de faire le bilan de ce que
donne le Grand Contournement Autoroutier
de Strasbourg qui en termes de
décarbonation et d'évaluation
d'évolution des trafics aux droits de
Strasbourg et sur l'axe nouveau c'est
pas tout à fait ce qui était annoncé
donc comment tenir ses orientations
claires nouvelle enfin deuxième question
très rapidement où trouver l'argent qui
va payer
parce que pour le ferroviaire le contrat
de performance c'est essentiellement
l'augmentation des pH ferroviaires qui
sont déjà parmi les plus élevés d'Europe
et si en disant ils prennent encore 28%
d'augmentation ce qui est prévu au
contrat de performance je crois c'est en
gros faire payer
pour le service TER quelque chose est
extrêmement coûteux et pour un réseau
qui qui est pas dans le meilleur état du
monde sur la question de parce qu'on on
envisage et c'est ce que disait la
première ministre de faire payer ceux
qui dégagent des profits très importants
du côté des autoroutes mais je crois que
le Conseil orientation d'infratus alerte
sur le fait qu'avec la disparition
progressive mais qui va arriver assez
rapidement c'est demain matin les
concessions tonières si ils veulent
répondre si on en reste aux règles
européennes existantes c'est de l'ordre
de 50 à 70% de ce que ça rapporte qui va
disparaître donc de ce fait là est-ce
qu'il faut pas réfléchir clairement
l'Alsace est précurseuse dans ce domaine
c'est ce qui est annoncé à faire payer
le fret routier au-delà des propositions
sur la rien et puis question comment
mettre en musique la loi de
programmation et la nécessité que le
volet les volets
des CPER soit déjà en cohérence avec
cette planification merci la parole
merci président merci
au membre du coi son président d'être
parmi nous et pouvoir répondre à nos
questions je vais être je pense beaucoup
plus courtes et je voudrais d'abord vous
demander quelle attention vous portez
vous parlez à juste titre de
modernisation du régénération du
ferroviaire vous parlez du retard
ferroviaire mais moi je voulais évoquer
avec vous un problème d'équité
territoriale et notamment puisque je
suis je suis sénatrice du lot d'une
partie du département du Lot qui peut se
considérer comme un territoire délaissé
un territoire abandonné un oubliée du
ferroviaire effectivement et je vais
vous parler de la ligne POLT la ligne
Paul il est question de son amélioration
on l'attend depuis très longtemps mais
cette ligne Paul elle est déclassée à de
Brive il n'y a plus il y a pas le même
nombre de trains tous les trains ne vont
pas jusqu'à Toulouse et
en dehors du fait que déjà les temps de
déplacement sont plus longs qu'à
l'époque du Capitole c'est que du fait
de cette ligne déclassée toute la partie
du nord du département et en quelque
sorte oubliée alors moi je n'ai rien
contre la LGV c'est très bien mais nous
n'allons pas pouvoir en bénéficier moi
personnellement là où j'habite une heure
et demie pour aller à Cahors donc je
vous dis pas pour aller à la gare TGV on
y est on ira pas prendre ce train là et
pour le coup qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
possibilité et là la question c'est de
quelle manière vous tenez compte de je
sais pas si on est dans la diagonale du
vide mais en tout cas voilà les
possibilités les offres ferroviaires
pour nous elles sont en train fortement
de se dégrader donc je voulais d'abord
évoquer ça et puis sur un sujet de
développement durable vous avez marqué
privilégié les mob réactive et donc je
voulais vous vous questionner sur le
vélo et notamment vous avez parlé de
partage mais est-ce que vous n'envisagez
pas de construction d'infrastructures
spécifiques pour le déplacement à vélo
parce que un problème de sécurité se
pose et le problème de partage avec les
voitures pose de questions de la
sécurité et je pense qu'il y aura un
frein au développement très fort que
pourraient connaître le vélo
sans qu'on ait des infrastructures
dédiées uniquement pour le vélo et si
vous aviez des chiffres à donner de
combien moins cher serait la bande de
roulement pour créer une piste cyclable
uniquement cyclable que pour les vélos
détachés complètement des des routes
destinées aux voitures pour m'indiquer
voilà pourquoi on va avoir une idée de
ce qu'il faudrait investir pour créer
toutes ces infrastructures qui je pense
serait nécessaire pour le la transition
écologique merci
la parole est à Jean-Claude Anglard
merci monsieur le Président alors ma
question puisqu'on est dans les
territoires oubliés je vais parler de
l'Aveyron je vais vous parler de la RN
de 88 de l'ARN 88 voilà le chaînon
manquant n'est-ce pas entre Rodez et ses
vagues-le-château ou on a bien dû votre
rapport vous préconisez de faire du
covoiturage ou prendre le bus je vous le
fais simple et ça nous inquiète beaucoup
au moment où un le Premier ministre
s'était engagé sur le sujet pour finir
ce tronçon ce phénom manquant de 60 km
deux ou les collectivités sont
proactives pour dire on va faire et donc
effectivement on a vraiment peur que
votre avis par rapport notamment aux
engagements de l'État voilà je sois pas
suivi des faits or on avait construit un
projet commun entre l'État et les
collectivités territoriales à la fois le
département et la région pour finir ce
schémaquant qui est essentiel pour le
désenclavagement du Sud Massif Central
puis il s'agit de rejoindre la 75
n'est-ce pas voilà depuis Rodez et
depuis Toulouse pour ceux qui est déjà
fait merci
il vous reste 20 minutes mais comme vous
eu très peu de questions ça devrait
aller
la parole c'est le Président
c'est une position assez confortable que
de dire que on ne pourra pas répondre à
toutes les questions quoi qu'il arrive
et je vais essayer de rassembler ce qui
peut l'être mais
bon d'abord il y a un sujet qui a été
évoqué sur la méthode je crois que c'est
le sénateur gilet qui qui en a parlé je
crois que c'est plus qu'un détail sur la
manière dont on a travaillé et cela de
temps de moi qui s'est passé
l'une des craintes qu'on pouvait avoir
j'en parle de très très franchement
puisque ça me concerne très directement
sur les travaux du Conseil c'était
d'avoir un rapport confortable pour
l'exécutif
en considérant que le son président
était un député membre de la majorité
et je crois avoir montré avec les
membres du conseil que nous avions
produits à un rapport qui en réalité
était pas si confortable que ça
et avait une certaine liberté il est
normal qu'on ait des échanges
sur l'atterrissage pas y compris avant
qu'on ait une ligne décrite et pendant
qu'on réfléchit avec avec l'exécutif
mais je crois pouvoir dire que aucun des
membres du Conseil n'a eu le sentiment
qu'il y avait une volonté d'orienter
vers quelque chose de façon très
systématique et qu'on a pu sénateur
Tabaro l'a dit cher Philippe travailler
avec beaucoup de liberté moi j'ai
vraiment essayé d'y veiller et ça c'est
c'est un point très important qui est eu
ensuite dans les différents états du
rapport puisque l'état définitif c'était
pas le 15 décembre les annexes n'étaient
pas rédigé au 15 décembre
donc elle n'est pas remise au
gouvernement non plus et je note que la
version qui avait fuité était celle qui
ne comportait que la synthèse générale
d'ailleurs c'était pas la version
définitive et que les annexes n'ont
peut-être jamais futé sauf erreur de ma
part or une grande partie des sujets qui
ont été évoqués ici concernent plutôt
les annexes que la synthèse générale du
rapport donc il a pu avoir des échanges
parfois des des points de vigilance je
pense notamment au montant des
investissements recommandés sur le
ferroviaire où on utilise plusieurs fois
le terme de minimum à propos de l'effort
qui est évoqué et où c'est évidemment un
terme qui est pas facile à endosser pour
un exécutif quel qu'il soit mais on l'a
maintenu
donc
je tiens à insister sur cette liberté
qui était la nôtre de travailler
et sur des conclusions qui sont pas
faciles à endosser quoi qu'il arrive
mais quand même puisque
à plusieurs reprises il a été fait
question de l'effort qui ne serait pas
assez important dans ce qui a été
annoncé je voudrais quand même dire et
là on peut je peux refaire un peu de
politique que c'est une charge bien
lourde que de penser que un gouvernement
dans un temps t va rattraper parfois des
décennies on parle pas juste de cinq ans
de sous-investissement sur le réseau et
sur leur routier et et quand même sur
ces sujets quand on essaye c'est
peut-être la déformation de la méthode
du coi quand on essaye de construire un
point de départ il faut aussi
reconnaître que l'effort depuis 5 ans a
été plus important que ce qui a précédé
et significativement plus important
et et ceci pour rebondir sur ce que
disait
sénateur Dominati
oui il y a eu des personnalités diverses
pour incarner les responsabilités en
même temps on a rarement autant parlé
des ministres des Transports sauf
peut-être avec Anne-Marie Idrac et
Dominique Bussereau que que ces
dernières années et on peut pas
considérer que la trajectoire de la
première ministre des Transports du
gouvernement de d'Édouard Philippe et
montrer que le sujet des transports
était si peu important que ça et si peu
considérer dans la vie publique et voilà
c'est c'est quand même c'est important
de le signaler
sur et je rebondis là-dessus parce que
ce sujet de la crédibilité des
engagements des uns des autres du je te
tiens par la barbichette on demande trop
aux régions on demande pas assez à
l'état etc c'est un sujet fondamental
il faut être au clair l'effort de
rattrapage est si important que un seul
acteur ne pourra pas y répondre
oui et c'est vrai sur toutes les
infrastructures existantes et sur le
routier et sur le ferroviaire parce
qu'il me semble avoir abordé assez
longuement le ferroviaire et le fluvial
dans mon rapport enfin dans ma
présentation initiale et donc oui les
collectivités seront sollicitées mais de
toute façon l'État lui aussi fera plus
et oui en plus de l'État des
collectivités il faudra trouver aussi
d'autres ressources
qu'elle soit fiscale
ou qu'elle soit en financement
alternatif mais de toute façon à la fin
il y a que deux façons de financer une
infrastructure de transport et un
service de transport c'est le
contribuable ou l'usager il y a pas
d'autres sources possibles et oui mais
l'Europe c'est pas non plus enfin on y
viendra mais donc le contribuable usager
et à cet égard si je partage ce qui a
été dit sur le fait que
proportionnellement notre dépense
publique contribue moins au financement
des infrastructures décarbonées et
singulièrement du ferroviaire
qu'ailleurs en Europe il faut aussi dire
pour aller jusqu'au bout du raisonnement
que en revanche nos usagers
et en fonctionnement ni contribue
beaucoup plus quand on parle de dépenses
publiques d'État il faudrait intégrer
celle des régions
ont sous-finance les investissements
dans le ferroviaire ont surfinance le
fonctionnement du ferroviaire
aujourd'hui avec des contributions
publiques et si vous regardez la part de
l'usager et du contribuable dans le
financement du service public
ferroviaire en Allemagne les ratios sont
absolument pas les mêmes qu'en France
donc en France le contribuable il
surfinance le service et sous-finance
l'investissement et dans les pays
étrangers c'est le contraire donc c'est
important de le de le réaliser et de le
voir comme ça et ce sujet des rapports
entre
l'État et les autres sources de
contribution possible des projets
d'infrastructures qui demandent la
sincérité des de tous les côtés
ce sujet il s'incarne à la fois dans la
manière dont les contrats de plan est en
région vont être discutés je le dis très
simplement mais les membres du coi qui
sont ici présents le savent quand on a
fait la remontée des je les dis tout à
l'heure déjà mais j'y insiste la
remontée des attentes des territoires
dans le rapport que nous avons remis
dans une certaine discrétion faut bien
le reconnaître en mars 2022 les
dialogues que nous avons eu avec les
territoires étaient de contenu très
inégaux
dans certains territoires on avait une
sélection des projets qui avait été
menés de façon très rigoureuse de sorte
à n'avoir que des projets qui pouvaient
être menés dans des calendriers à peu
près réalistes
et dans d'autres qui n'étaient
d'ailleurs pas forcément les mieux
placés du point de vue de l'exécution
des contrats de planétarius
on avait une liste de projets qui allait
du rond-point giratoire jusqu'à
l'infrastructure structurante et ça ça
n'est pas sérieux
ça n'est pas sérieux et donc si quand on
demande au gouvernement de sortir des
effets d'annonce je crois que tout le
monde doit sortir des effets d'annonce
y compris les acteurs publics locaux des
collectivités et je le dis Philippe la
rappeler j'ai été vice-président de
région je suis toujours conseillé
régional j'ai été maire j'étais
président d'agglomération donc je vois à
quel point c'est tentant parfois
d'annoncer des calendriers très
optimistes sur des infrastructures ou de
promettre que la mise à deux fois de
voix d'un tronçon qui ne l'est pas va
résoudre tous les problèmes donc la
demande du territoire mais ça n'est pas
toujours très sérieux
et pour revenir et rebondir rebondir sur
un des sujets qui étaient abordés qui
est celui de pourquoi avez-vous évoqué
tel projet plutôt que tel autre
mais parce que c'est le niveau
d'engagement de l'État parce que nous on
se prononce essentiellement sur la
capacité de l'État à contribuer en
examine d'abord les projets sur lesquels
la contribution de l'État est élevée là
où elle est attendue
mais ne pas être évoqué par le Conseil
dans son rapport ça ne veut pas dire que
un projet n'est pas important je dis ça
pour madame la sénatrice bonne foi
Angoulême Limoges c'est une petite ligne
c'est une ligne UC cette année sur le
plan technique et donc quand on parle
des petites lignes ferroviaires à
l'échelle nationale on parle notamment
d'Angoulême Limoges et aujourd'hui sur
Angoulême Limoges sauf erreur de ma part
il y a un accord qui a été signé avec la
région nouvelle Aquitaine par l'État sur
l'ensemble du réseau des petites lignes
puisque c'est la deuxième région la plus
concernée je crois la première même avec
Occitanie
et donc aujourd'hui ce que les uns et
les autres se sont engagés à faire et
dans quel calendrier souhaité c'est
public c'est pas une surprise et donc
il y a eu une classification des petites
lignes en trois catégories celles qui
sont réinjectées dans le réseau
structurant ça n'est pas le cas je crois
d'Angoulême Limoges celles qui font
l'objet de financement croisés de l'État
et des régions
éventuellement d'autres partenaires dans
le cadre des CPR et celles qui sont
reprises à 100% au financement régional
je crois que la ligne Angoulême image
relève de la deuxième catégorie donc
elle fera l'objet de la négociation CPER
mais on sait aujourd'hui à peu près et
ça n'est pas juste à l'état seul de
vouloir la réalité d'Angoulême Limoges
parce que là aussi on peut dire que le
sujet du financement sur les petites
lignes ça ne devrait dépendre que l'État
c'est une vision théorique mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que l'État consacre plus
d'argent aujourd'hui aux petites lignes
ferroviaires maintenant
qui n'y consacrait avant puisque avant
on disait qu'on faisait tout et on ne
faisait rien sur cette ligne et
aujourd'hui on dit qu'on fait un peu et
on fait un peu mais c'est déjà plus que
rien donc je donc il y a pas du tout de
mépris pour Angoulême Limoges ni
structurante et un masségar la vie qu'on
a émis sur la 147 d'ailleurs sur
Poitiers Limoges qui est un avis négatif
il est aussi lié à la nécessité pour
nous de pas toujours
surfinancer des projets routiers en
oubliant des projets ferroviaires qui
sont importants pour les territoires je
vous le dis
sur
les les sujets de de
l'aérien on a effectivement on n'était
pas mandatés pour aborder l'aérien de
front pas plus d'ailleurs qu'en 2018 on
en a parlé uniquement sur sur le sujet
de Mayotte puisque la nouveauté dans le
rapport c'est qu'on a abordé les
outre-mer ce qui était pas le cas la
fois précédent on a eu des temps
d'échanges très très nourri avec les
outre-mer dans lesquels on considère que
une partie des raisonnements sur la
priorisation des infrastructures qu'on
élabore pour la métropole ne peut pas
complètement s'appliquer compte tenu des
contraintes spécifiques à ces
territoires c'est pas à moi de de en
tout cas pas en tant que président du
coi d'émettre des avis sur les
carburants alternatifs aéronautiques et
leur insuffisance développement en
France je crois qu'il y a déjà une
structure qui fonctionne un petit
échelle dans les Bouches-du-Rhône il y a
un projet en Seine-et-Marne qui va je
pense aboutir bientôt mais en effet il y
a un enjeu de production en France de
ces carburants alternatifs aéronautique
sur l'Europe c'est un sujet assez
fondamental
je précise qu'on a auditionné le
directeur général des transports le DG
move lors du premier rapport pour qu'on
parle assez franchement de la capacité
contributive de l'Europe le constat
principal qu'on peut faire c'est que
il y a un loup
quand vous faites la somme projet par
projet évidemment tout le monde à part
l'état personne n'est en capacité de
faire cette somme cette addition là mais
enfin quand même quand vous faites la
somme projet par projet
des financements européens attendus à
l'échelle nationale sur les
infrastructures de transport vous
aboutissez à une contribution attendue
de l'Europe qui représente la moitié des
investissements disponibles pour la
période à venir à l'échelle de toute
l'Union européenne
et je sais que la France est à Nice et
donc par définition un lieu de passage
et de important pour toute l'Europe mais
je ne crois pas que nous absorberons la
moitié des financements européens en
matière de transport dans les années qui
viennent donc il y a forcément un effet
de surestimation et on n'est pas
forcément sorti de ce qui se faisait
traditionnellement à savoir un tour de
table pour lancer un projet
d'infrastructure il manque un peu on est
pas si loin que ça du RTT qui passe pas
loin donc on dit l'Europe finira par
financer on a quelques contacts sans
engagement précis mais on le met dans le
plan de financement et puis on se dit
que à la fin si l'Europe dit qu'elle
peut pas on verra bien
donc on est on n'est pas complètement
sorti de ça sur beaucoup de projets et y
compris sur certains qui ont été évoqués
le Conseil a été amené à parfois sans
l'écrire et parfois on l'écrivant à
estimer que l'attente de contribution ne
serait peut-être pas au rendez-vous du
côté européen de ce qui était
aujourd'hui dans les plantes financement
et je dis y compris dans des projets qui
ont été évoqués ici et de façon
récurrente
sur les réseaux Express
métropolitains et sur la SGP
le sujet je pense pas qu'on puisse
parler de Miss sous tutelle d'autant que
le discussions je pense que beaucoup le
savent ici entre la Société du Grand
Paris et SNCF réseau sont des
discussions qui se font bien et dans
lesquels chacun je crois que il faut pas
être obsédé dans cette question de
portage par le sujet de la recette là
aussi il y aura pas d'argent magique
et la capacité contributive des
territoires dans un certain nombre de
cas on peut en douter qu'elles soient si
importante que ça et après tout même sur
GPSO elle est pas principale dans le
financement du projet elle elle vient en
Suisse
mais c'est le sujet fondamental et
l'intérêt de cette formule c'est la
capacité à faire je le disais beaucoup
plus que la capacité à financer la
capacité à faire parce que
la LGP a développé une méthode de
travail en plateau projet une capacité à
rendre des comptes aux financeur
qui aujourd'hui
font défaut pour partie à SNCF réseau
qui est par avoir un plan de charge qui
va qui va être accéléré et nourri et
donc c'est c'est en cela que la solution
est intéressante beaucoup plus qu'en
matière de financement je crois et là je
me permets de m'exprimer à titre
personnel
si tu veux compléter certains des
nombreux points que j'ai oublié
alors sur le lion tirage je crois que
vous m'attendez
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
d'être présent et de l'ampleur des
questionnements que vous que le rapport
suscite et je pense qu'on peut
poursuivre au-delà de cette audition les
échanges pour bien se comprendre si je
commence par le lion Turin la première
des choses qui me frappe sur le lien
Turin c'est que l'estimation a
terminaison du projet et le calendrier
n'a pas été réajusté depuis plusieurs
années
c'est une situation qui n'est pas
acceptable vous l'évoquiez à propos
d'autres projets sur la question du la
tenue des coûts et des délais c'est
typiquement une opération sur laquelle
nous devrions avoir tous les six mois
une réestimation des coûts et des délais
ça n'est pas le cas depuis plusieurs
années
donc nous avons fait des hypothèses dans
les
quinquennat postérieur à l'échéance que
vous évoquiez qui qui reste une échéance
extrêmement optimiste semble-t-il à ce
stade de l'ouverture du tunnel
nous avons dû prendre des hypothèses sur
des
poursuites d'imputations dans les
crédits d'État de la finalisation de ce
tunnel bien entendu d'ici là et j'espère
dans quelques mois il y aura des
estimations qui seront sur la table et
qui permettront de justifier les choses
l'objectif de base pour le pour le lion
Turin le président la valence c'est que
à l'ouverture on puisse faire circuler à
peu près 15 millions de tonnes de
marchandises à destination de de ce
tunnel qui correspond à quelque chose
qui est disons à peine supérieur ou 10
millions de tonnes qui circulaient déjà
dans
antérieurement on est tombé à moins de 3
millions de tonnes pour des raisons qui
tiennent beaucoup à l'ouverture des
tunnels alternatifs et aux déploiement
de grands flux de fret qui depuis le
nord de l'Europe
le ce que nous appelons dans le rapport
la première phase des accès aux lions
Turin c'est la combinaison du céphal
Nord
projet dont le président Valence a
rappelé que ça fait des années qu'il est
dupé on parlait de la DUP des
accès mais le Céphale est DUP depuis
2012 sans que aucun protocole de
financement n'ait été signé par qui que
ce soit ils sont qu'on sache comment il
va être réalisé aujourd'hui et on
parlait de la Société du Grand Projet
voilà un projet qui mérite en toute
urgence parce qu'il est nécessaire pour
le réseau express métropolitain lyonnais
il est il est indispensable pour
déplacer le frais de ferroviaire vers
venant du Nord
ce projet est crucial
l'élargissement de Saint-Fons Grenay
c'est peut-être donc la mise à quatre
voix c'est également crucial et ses
crucial pour pour les flux cette fois-ci
venant du Sud dont on parlait c'est ce
fameux axe
de alors je sais plus de Lisbonne à Kiev
c'est la première des choses c'est
effectivement d'être capable de capter
ce flux on a proposé d'y adjointe parce
que c'était le résultat des
conversations et des discussions locales
c'est encore contesté par un certain
nombre d'acteurs un franchissement du
Rhône qui permette de de réaliser les
choses sur le Céphale Sud qui est le
l'axe qui permet et qui est vraiment le
lieu de la congestion il y a toujours
pas de consensus
nous avons encore reçu des nouvelles
interventions multiples sur la façon
dont il fallait passer soit le long de
la LGV soit plus au nord etc donc tous
ces sujets là sont les sujets qui feront
que à l'ouverture du tunnel il y aura 15
millions de tonnes c'est pas Dijon
Modane sol c'est l'ensemble de ces de
ces projets et il y en a pour de l'ordre
de 5 milliards d'euros quand même
d'engagement de travaux donc c'est c'est
là-dessus que nous avons concentré
effectivement le la tension
sur les les nouveaux tunnels les
nouvelles les sections en
ligne nouvelle nous avons effectivement
pas intégré dans la planification
écologique un calendrier très précoce
sauf que et ça fait partie des choses il
y avait quelques erreurs dans le tableau
de synthèse qui ont pu induire un
certain nombre de lecteurs et qui ont
été corrigés donc je voulais le dire en
fait les les versions successives sont
des versions de correction de coquilles
c'est à dire comme nous avons travaillé
dans une urgence absolue jusqu'à début
janvier pour rendre les annexes nous
avions des problèmes de coordination
entre le texte et les tableaux le texte
principal qui ont fait qu'on a passé
notre temps à refaire des nouvelles
versions mais c'est il n'y a pas eu un
mot de changer sur le fond c'était
uniquement de l'amélioration donc
normalement la version qui est en ligne
est aujourd'hui stabilisée et
les tableaux sont en cohérence avec nos
propositions
le scénario le plus haut lui active les
accès donc nous n'y aurions pas que
c'est une des options à la position du
gouvernement
sur l'implication de la SGP sur les
réseaux sur ce que nous appelons les
services express régionaux métropolitain
nous tenons à la fois au terme de
services il s'agit de services c'est
régional et ses métropolitains les trois
termes sont sont essentiels c'est-à-dire
que ça n'est pas un des transports
collectifs urbains de l'échelle
métropolitaine c'est bien pour aller
capter la capacité d'organiser
l'urbanisation entre des sur des grands
axes dans lesquels il y a une densité
d'usage suffisant et sur ces projets là
c'est d'abord un sujet de service
et c'est dans un certain nombre de cas
des travaux neufs considérables à
réaliser il y en a quelques-uns il y en
a pas énormément ce qui est déjà engagé
c'est les travaux de pour Marseille avec
les PCA et les travaux sous Marseille
Nice Toulon il y a Bordeaux qui est
engagé aussi très volonté de façon très
volontariste il y a il y a Strasbourg
qui a déjà fait des progrès et il y a
tout un ensemble de projets qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas totalement
matures dans certains il y a des
liaisons et des travaux neufs à réaliser
et la Société du Grand Paris comme l'a
dit David et extrêmement compétente pour
porter des projets de cette nature et il
y a l'enjeu plus délicat de travailler
sur le réseau existant pour un certain
nombre de d'adaptations et d'aménagement
dans lequel SNCF réseau à tous les
atouts pour le faire de façon
coordonnées parce que quand on parle de
ces investissements et de tous ces
travaux encore faut-il concilier la
programmation et le volontarisme avec le
fait qu'il faut continuer à faire
circuler des trains il faut continuer à
faire circuler donc on peut pas être en
travaux partout en même temps et
n'importe comment et donc ce que nous
avons proposé c'est une montée en
puissance qui développe les capacités
d'intervention et quand on parlait de
l'Italie pour moi la première référence
de l'Italie c'est que eux ils seront
avec un ERTS déployé en 2030 sur
l'ensemble de leurs réseaux tel qu'ils
sont partis donc ce que nous nous voyons
avec nos collègues allemands ou nos
collègues italien c'est que nous
n'assurerons pas l'interopérabilité qui
est nécessaire et nous ne ferons pas les
économies d'exploitation qui sont liées
au fait que on supprime la signalisation
latérale et donc on a quelque chose de
beaucoup plus efficace si nous ne
donnons pas sur ces aspects 500 dans un
premier temps puis un milliard si vous
lisez bien le rapport donc c'est bien
une montée en puissance qui permet en
2040 2042 d'avoir fait le réseau central
on ne parle pas du de l'ensemble du
réseau si on arrive à cet effort
collectif d'avoir mobilisé des moyens
considérables sur ces aspects c'est
effectivement quelque chose de tout à
fait stratégique du point de vue du
réseau européen et c'est sans aucun
doute en tout cas dans ce que nous avons
écrit beaucoup plus important que tout
le reste d'être à ce rendez-vous là la
régénération la commande centralisée du
réseau pour assurer de la performance de
l'opérateur l'opérateur aujourd'hui
ne peut pas avoir de performances
opérationnelle parce que son système
d'aiguillages pour leur dire simplement
obsolède vétust etc il doit moderniser
son outil de production et il doit
s'engager et ça rejoint le débat sur le
contrat de performance sur le fait que à
terme ça dégage des capacités de
productivité qui permettent d'optimiser
les choses monsieur et le dernier point
est-ce que j'ai terminé je suis confus
les plateformes logistiques alors j'ai
été pris entre
deux territoires que je dans lesquels
j'ai opéré à la fois la somme et l'aube
et donc je vois bien de quoi parler le
sédataire de millions en particulier il
y a un projet d'une quinzaine de
plateformes qui est portée dans le cadre
du Conseil national de l'industrie
par les opérateurs céréaliers etc avec
des opérateurs aujourd'hui il s'agit
d'après ce que j'ai compris d'accélérer
les études de ces de ces opérations et
grosso modo ce qui est dit dans les
documents qui circulent c'est qu'il
faudrait dans le quinquet qui vient
consacrer 150 millions de à ces
opérations avec une part des régions et
des et de l'État qui est sollicitée aux
alentours de 30%. donc ça fait dans les
comptes du budget de l'État dont nous
parlons pour le quinquennat en cours au
grand maximum une quinzaine de millions
une trentaine de millions si on veut le
être
dans 2 millions
sur les plateformes logistiques la
question qui a été abordée par plusieurs
d'entre vous
voilà
excusez-moi donc c'était et c'est pour
dire justement votre
votre réaction a été exactement
l'illustration de ce que je voulais dire
c'est que nous ne l'avons pas mis en
avant parce que voilà on a fait un
rapport qui traite de globalité et on
n'est pas descendu à des mailles de
quelques millions quelques dizaines de
millions et donc ça n'est pas du tout
exclusif dans l'esprit du coi mais
simplement il n'y avait pas la place on
a déjà beaucoup écrit pour témoigner de
tous les projets et puis autre
territoire
que je connais un peu mais plutôt pour
des raisons familiales qui est la RN88
dans l'Aveyron là effectivement on a on
a émis un point de vue on savait on sait
bien que pendant qu'on discutait au sein
du coi il y avait les débats de la loi
3DS et que les collectivités se
positionnaient autour de ces questions
donc le débat va continuer à prospérer
les projets vont
s'approfondir ce que nous a donc vont
dit de façon générale c'est que
aujourd'hui
l'énergie a des pensées du point de vue
d'appuissance publique et beaucoup plus
sur les bornes de recharge pour
permettre aux véhicules de circuler avec
des nouvelles motorisations que sur des
mises à deux fois de voix dans des quand
le trafic le nécessite pas absolument
voilà c'est une position qui
effectivement n'est pas exactement celle
qui a été prise dans la chronologie de
ce projet
on en serait pas là et on aurait même
pas le scénario faut quand même l'avoir
en tête
quand je parle tout à l'heure de
financement je dis on peut plus
continuer certains parler de l'aérien
vous avez toujours des annonces à une
époque on allait prendre 400 millions
d'euros sur les agences de l'eau là on
voit les accélérer aériens
l'hydrogène on va les donner 400
millions d'euros l'hydrogène on va les
donner un milliard aux collectivités
locales sur le fond vert bref lorsque
j'ai dit à la première ministre c'est
qu'on avait du mal à voir l'ensemble et
on m'a répondu parce que je crois que
c'est toi qui pose la question au mois
de juin sur les infras sur le logement
sur l'énergie on devrait avoir une
vision un peu plus globale avec un
planning et des
financements donc attendons le mois de
juin un mot sur lasagne évidemment que
les ânes vont nous poser des problèmes
ça c'est et le travail que vous faites
aujourd'hui pour donner des outils ça me
semble
indispensable les surcoûts on parle de
surcoût mais souvent on a des budgets
qui datent d'années et d'années avant
qui sont pas réactualisés et quand vous
prenez en plus aujourd'hui de
l'inflation vous à un moment ça devient
extrêmement compliqué et un dernier mot
je pense que si on ne sort pas du pacte
de stabilité sur les 3% avec les 3% sur
les investissements pour décarboner on y
arrivera pas ça c'est une vie
personnelle mais il y a tellement
tellement à mettre sur la table c'est
pour ça que je disais tout à l'heure il
faut avoir une réflexion globale sur le
financement parce que David le rappeler
c'est où l'usager ou le contribuable qui
paye merci pour terminer vraiment sur
ces sujets de de méthodes et de temps
long
si on fait une comparaison européenne de
la manière dont le portage des
investissements sur les infrastructures
de transport se fait la plupart du temps
on a des lois qui dépassent l'échelle de
5 ans mais qui sont révisés tous les 5
ans donc on pourrait très bien imaginer
une loi à 10 ans qui soit qui fait
l'objet d'une révision tous les 5 ans et
finalement
nous sommes déjà en train d'écrire à
partir de rien parce que ce dont on
parle il y a 20 ans ou 30 ans on en
était très très loin on est déjà en
train d'écrire quelque chose qui
ressemble puisque finalement ce qu'a
fait le COI à travers ce rapport c'est
actualiser le rapport durant de 2018 et
donc on y est il nous manque le véhicule
principal de la loi de programmation
décennales mais contrairement je le dis
à ce que j'entends parfois évidemment il
y aura toujours des difficultés à
financer des projets ça n'est pas propre
à la France ça se voit aussi à
l'étranger l'obstacle principal
principal du fait qu'on puisse avancer
avec
sincérité de façon à créer de la
crédibilité de la parole publique et de
l'ambition en matière de décarbonation
sur ces sujets c'est la culture
politique française
notre capacité à construire du consensus
et à nous faire confiance
et à assumer des choix qui ne sont pas
toujours simples
et si on avait une évolution de cela je
pense que
on ne serait pas en permanence d'abord
en train de parler de projet nouveau
mais on consacrerait des moyens à ce qui
existe cette remarquable pour évaluer
pour le nucléaire comme elle vaut pour
les infrastructures de transport et on
saurait se mettre d'accord et assumer
des positions qui sont parfois
difficiles sur la priorisation de projet
ce qui n'a pas toujours été la
caractéristique principale de notre
culture politique
état et collectivités territoriales à
part mais le COI a un début de réponse à
tout cela ce que j'espère c'est que le
Sénat pourra aussi relayer cette
nécessité d'être dans la une forme de
parler vrai et pas seulement dans le
toujours plus mais tout simplement en
disant ce qui peut être fait quand et
comment
merci merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le vice-président monsieur le
rapporteur général merci de d'être
soumis à nos questions merci à mon
collègue président de la commission des
finances pour cette audition commune je
pense que effectivement elle était
particulièrement intéressante
particulièrement motivante et on voit
bien tout le travail qu'il y a à faire
entre la modernisation et puis les
créations et puis merci merci aux
rapporteur merci aux membres de la
commission des finances d'être présent
et merci à ceux de la commission
d'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable effectivement vous
avez fait une conclusion qui est
importante il va falloir que l'on cadre
les choses qu'on fasse des choses et
puis que on ne se disperse peut-être pas
partout ce qui nous paraîtrait fort
intéressant mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
tellement de besoins depuis plusieurs
années rien que dans la mise au norme au
niveau ferroviaire que on a
effectivement beaucoup de travail merci
pour cette présentation de ce rapport
et pour ces et ceux qui n'auraient pas
eu la réponse complète alors question si
vous voulez on pourra peut-être vous
adresser un petit courrier pour que vous
puissiez effectivement vous donner les
réponses adéquates merci bon appétit